So, hoffentlich rockt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Oh, und wir haben sogar Qualitätsoptionen.
Ups, krasser Schett.
So, live oder nicht live, ja jetzt wieder live, sogar mit Qualitätsoptionen, guck mal.
Poggers, Alter, Poggers.
Nachher noch Black Ops 4, ja, später irgendwann vielleicht noch mal Black Ops 4, weil ich
hab grad, ich hab mehr oder weniger seit um halb 10 oder so Black Ops gespielt, vorher
noch ein bisschen Blackout mit dem Ejax zusammen, haben eine richtig schöne Runde gehabt, wo
sie alle weggebasht haben, besser gesagt der Ejax hat sie weggebasht und ich hab mitgespielt.
Aber, jetzt muss ich mich erstmal wieder ein bisschen geistig da von Black Ops erholen,
deswegen zeige ich euch mal, wie ich das Memetool verbessert hab, das ist jetzt richtig sophisticated
mittlerweile.
Ich muss nur mal gucken, welchen Port das verwendet, kann man eigentlich den Port einstellen.
Und dann will ich heute noch was anderes mit euch machen, nämlich, wie hab ich keine Anzeige,
wie viele Leute zugucken, sowas mit Twitch-Los heute.
So, das Beste ist die Mode, gestern dachte ich die Abo-Box-Spin, ja eigentlich hatte ich
das gar nicht vor, dass mich überkam es irgendwie so, als ich Black Ops gespielt hab, ich weiß
auch nicht woran das liegt.
Übrigens Leute, nur für die, die neu da sind, ich kann nicht nur 0.3d'en, ich kann
sogar 0.4d'en, das ist absolut die höchste Lull-Evolutionsstufe, die es gibt, ich glaube
man könnte das bloß noch toppen mit Omega-Lull-4d, dann wäre es glaube ich vorbei.
Jetzt wollte ich es jetzt zeigen, genau, und zwar, also wir basteln heute noch ein bisschen
an dem Tool weiter rum, ich weiß, es muss ja mal irgendwann noch was halbwegs Benutzbares
für alle rauskommen, nicht nur, dass es bei mir funktioniert, ich hab jetzt eingebaut,
dass man nicht mehr die Bildchen hier im Fallsystem haben muss, sondern dass man die in der Datenbank
speichern kann, was auch ganz praktisch ist, weil Fallsystem an sich gerät dann relativ
schnell an seine Grenzen, wenn man ein bisschen mehr machen will, und ganz wichtig, was ich
jetzt eigentlich hauptsächlich machen will, bisher kann das ja noch nicht viel, außer
die Windows, und ich wollte mal gucken, also wir brauchen nämlich mehrere Text-to-Speech-Sachen,
es reicht ja nicht, dass dieses Ding quasi Overlay-Bilder anzeigen lassen kann oder
sowas, das ist nicht genug, sondern wir brauchen natürlich auch noch irgendwelchen blöden
Text-to-Speech-Kram, und wie das mit Windows-Bordmittel funktioniert, haben wir das letzte Mal gesehen,
ich kann das jetzt nochmal kurz zeigen, aber, ups, das wollte ich nicht starten, das hab
ich schon gestartet, ich wollte eigentlich noch die Visual Studio Instance aufmachen,
aber wir müssen jetzt versuchen noch ein paar mehr Text-to-Speech-Stimmen reinzukriegen,
also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall die richtig krasse Weep-Anime-Weep-Stimme, also quasi
nach dem Motto Monkeist, Monkeist, oder sowas in der Richtung, brauchen wir, Console-App,
ja passt schon, ich zeig jetzt nochmal kurz, wie das mit dem eingebauten Text-to-Speech
von Windows funktioniert, das muss ich mir aber abgucken, das muss ich mir aber abgucken
aus meinem eigenen Programm, so und dann das wichtigste ist, wir müssen uns irgendeinen
Weep-Text-to-Speech-Service suchen, ich hab keine Ahnung, was es gibt, also wir müssen
allgemein mal gucken, was es für Text-to-Speech-Services gibt, also wie gesagt, ich hab bisher Text-to-Speech
nur mit dem Windows-Bordmittel gemacht, so warte mal, ich muss mal nachgucken, wie ging
das hier nochmal, also wir machen jetzt nochmal kurz Text-to-Speech-Windows-Bordmittel, genau,
das war eigentlich mega easy, und wie gesagt, wir spielen später noch ein paar Runden Black
Ops, aber ich muss jetzt erstmal mich ein bisschen ausruhen und dann Abendessen und
dann spielen wir Black Ops in 2 Stunden oder so, Discord hat ein gutes Text-to-Speech,
was, Discord hat Text-to-Speech, ernsthaft, hab ich noch nie verwendet, so, kluen wir
das Ganze mal, jawoll, perfekt, so, jetzt machen wir mal TTS, Say oder Speak, woops, ich kann
den mal tippen, hallo, was zum Teufel tippt der denn hier, Klammer auf, warum machst du
ein Sternchen, wenn ich Klammer aufmache, die Tasten sind bei mir gerade eins fest, ah,
ich weiß, woran das liegt, weil ich das indische Keyboard habe, Windows ist der Meinung, das
hatte mir beim Sprachpaket installieren als Default eingerichtet, Englisch plus Indisches
Keyboard, so, warum auch immer, so, wir machen jetzt mal ein Text, mit dem Standard-Windows-Text-to-Speech,
das ist relativ, das hört sich halt scheiße an, das will ich nicht verwenden, mal gucken,
ob man das hört, ah, das ist natürlich nicht, das ist nicht sophisticated genug für unsere
Sachen, aber bevor wir die ganzen Text-to-Speech-Geschichte machen, sollte ich euch vielleicht mal die
neue Meme-Board-Version zeigen, oder, was ich mir da ausgedacht hab, also ich finde,
das ist halt dumm, oder, das ist richtig dumm, oder, hier, das ist richtig dumm, guckt mal,
der Sebaro hat uns schon den ersten Link für japanische Text-to-Speech gepaustet, gucken
wir mal, aber das muss man, also das Sebaro, das klingt so, als müsste man sich das lizenzieren,
was blöd ist, ich will ja irgendwas kostenloses, so, die Windows Text-to-Speech, das klingt
so richtig, weiß ich so, so ohne Emotionen irgendwie, kann sich Alexa nehmen, wir könnten,
wir könnten, ah, Amazon Polly könnten wir nehmen, aber Amazon Polly kostet auch Geld,
das ist ziemlich dumm, wenn Amazon Polly Geld kostet, ich zeige euch erstmal die neue Meme-Board-Version,
vorher muss ich ja mal gucken, dass die auf einem anderen Port läuft, wie die alte, die
auch immer man das macht, wie ändert man den Port in ASP.NET, ich hab keine Ahnung,
gucken wir mal, wie ändert man den Port, how to specify port, weil die voll ist 5000,
ja ich weiß, use worlds, ok, ja, so machen wir das, perfekt, Stack Overflow Driven Programming,
also wenn ihr irgendwann mal was erreichen wollt, in der Richtung Stack Overflow, beste,
kannst du nicht Omega-Lul anders schreiben, ich weiß nicht, aber ich will das ja gar
nicht mit dem Windows, ich brauche eben so eine tolle Weep Text-to-Speech, ich kann
das nicht nachmachen, ich kann keine Weep-Stimmen nachmachen, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
brauche ich, so, jetzt läuft es zu 5001, das ist schon mal gut, jetzt muss ich bloß an
meinem, so noch hier sagen, dass es auf Port 5001 läuft, achso, brauchen wir gar nicht,
sehr schön, so, also ich zeige euch jetzt mal die neue Minboard-Variante, neue Minboard-Version,
so und ich hoffe, das mit dem Port hat jetzt funktioniert, also es funktioniert noch nicht
alles, ja, aber man sieht schon mal, dass die Oberfläche viel schöner ist und dass
eine Datenbank dahinter ist, dass das Ganze klar viel besser macht, eigentlich sollte
ich jetzt den Browser aufgehen, da ist es doch, da ist es doch, so, jetzt ist noch nichts
drin, das ist die neue Oberfläche, man erkennt noch nicht allzu viel, hier unten sind dann
die Bildchen drinnen und hier oben kann man suchen, sieht ein bisschen aus wie die alte
Oberfläche, plus, dass das jetzt deutlich konsistenter ist, das Ganze, man hat einen
schönen Theme-Button hier oben in der Ecke und ja, Programming ist outdated, jetzt ist
Science and Technology angesagt, so und jetzt kann man zum Beispiel hier ein Bildchen nehmen,
nehmen wir jetzt mal hier zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, Eats, Eats PNG, dann sieht man hier,
wie schön hier das Track and Drop schon funktioniert, Achtung Leute, pass mal auf, das kennen wir
noch, das haben wir im alten auch noch gemacht, du ziehst das drüber, geht jetzt auf, dann
lässt du es los, Bam, Upload Dialog, Upload Dialog, wo du einstellen kannst, wie das Ding
heißen soll, irgendeinen Text-to-Speech-Text, falls du einen brauchst, du kannst das muten
oder unmuten, also sprich, falls du Text-to-Speech und Bilder machen willst, also ich muss sagen,
das sieht schon sehr sophisticated aus, ne und, also hier habe ich schon mal ein paar
Stimmen vorgefertigt, die es halt noch nicht gibt, das müssen wir heute machen, heute
müssen wir passende Text-to-Speech-Anbieter finden dafür, kann man muten, dann macht
man Upload, zack und dann ist es da, der Dialog sollte noch zugehen eigentlich, so und dann
hat man hier das Web-Interface und, und das Web-Interface funktioniert nicht, warum funktioniert
das Web-Interface nicht, ist da Vorführeffekt jetzt, ich glaube das liegt daran, dass ich
hier nicht auf Port 5001 gehe, sondern auf 5000, Omega Lull, so nochmal starten, da war
es richtig Vorführeffekt, ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum kein Plaza-Fenster mehr aufgeht,
wahrscheinlich geht das nur mit 5000 oder so, so Eats, alter was, Teff, Monkeys, Monkeys,
ja also normalerweise, also ich habe es vorhin ausprobiert, da hat es noch funktioniert,
da kam das Overlay jetzt, wenn man da draufklickt, ja warum funktioniert denn das nicht, das
muss man jetzt mal kurz angucken, warum das nicht funktioniert, weil das sollte prinzipiell
eigentlich gehen, warum geht denn das nicht, das müssen wir uns mal kurz hier raus kriegen,
so wo ist denn hier das Update, blablabla, wo connectet er sich denn hier nochmal, ja
50001, also prinzipiell sollte das funktionieren, boah was mit dem Soundschuss, ist das Overlay
in OBS, nein das hat mit OBS überhaupt nichts zu tun, ich will mal gucken ob das überhaupt
angeworfen wird, aber das liegt bestimmt daran, dass ich den Port geändert habe, 100%, aber
mich wundert es auch, dass kein Browser automatisch aufgeht, vielleicht hätte ich doch nicht
den Port ändern sollen, the fuck ist das, also prinzipiell toggelt das, aber das toggelt
das, das funktioniert doch, aber es zeigt kein Overlay an, ich bin verwirrt Leute, eigentlich
sollte das funktionieren, aber das ist jetzt echt typisch Frau für Effekt, aber ich meine
vielleicht ist das Konflikt mit dem alten Tool, ich weiß es nicht, komisch, sollte eigentlich
ja mit überhaupt nichts zu tun haben, ich mach das alte Tool jetzt mal aus, das ist
richtig early access, ja für die Leute die neu sind, die nicht wissen warum man sowas
braucht, ist einfach so, man kann ja im OBS so Overlay Bildchen einblenden, das funktioniert
ja, das Problem ist, dass man das im OBS nur selbst sieht, also Schwachsinn, dass man
das im OBS nicht selbst sieht und ich will die Overlay Bildchen selbst sehen, ohne dass
sie mich beeinflussen, also man kann durchklicken durch die Overlay Bildchen und es wird auch
kein Fokus dadurch weggenommen, also sprich die kann ich quasi während ich irgendwas
streame und zeichne dann zack einblenden, ohne dass es das Spiel irgendwie stört, ohne
dass es mich aus dem Spiel rausreißt, also sprich ohne dass es ein Fenster minimiert oder
sowas, das interagiert eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht, mit irgendwas was darunter liegt
und ich sehe die Bilder selbst, das heißt ich kann sie nicht vergessen auszumachen,
also Leute ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen verwirrt, warum das nicht funktioniert, lassen
wir uns mal den fad anzeigen, ob das vielleicht nicht funktioniert hat, wenn das drüber gelegt
wird was sagen, dann anticheats dazu, ich vermute mal gar nichts, das kann man allerdings
nicht sicher sagen, der Aufruf verbindet sich überhaupt nicht, ich bin mega verwirrt
gerade, ich bin echt verwirrt, warum das nicht funktioniert, das muss man wahrscheinlich
danach nochmal in Ruhe angucken, warum das nicht geht, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es
überhaupt irgendjemand interessiert, weil man muss ja dazu sagen, hier das zum Beispiel,
seht ihr das, seht ihr das, ich muss mal in der Vorschau gucken, das ist das Shadowplay
Overlay, falls man das sieht, sieht man das, sag mir mal wieder ob man das sieht, wenn
man das sieht, das ist ja im Prinzip genau das gleiche was die machen, nur mit dem Unterschied,
die sind schlechter, man kann nicht durchklicken, bei mir kann man durchklicken und da sagt
ja auch kein anticheat was dagegen, sag mal irgendwas ist hier doch im Arsch oder, also
irgendwas ist hier voll kaputt, ich mach mal, ich mach mal das andere, das alte Tool aus,
mach mal hier rückgängig, rückgängig auf 5000 und im Startup auch mal rückgängig,
wenn ich im Startup hier mal rückgängig, oder gucke ich mal ob es funktioniert, das
weiß ich irgendwie, hä, ok ich hab es irgendwie, sag mal kann das sein, dass irgendwie mal
ein Tastatur rumspackt oder so, was macht das da, da soll das markieren und nicht blau
machen, das ist sehr sehr merkwürdig, vielleicht liegt es auch daran, was zum Teufel ist hier
los, wartet mal ich muss jetzt mal hier suspenden, ja das ist halt so der richtig geile Vorführeffekt,
ein bisschen Prozess Explorer, dass wir mal gucken können ob ich hier irgendeinen Scheiß
im Hintergrund laufen hab oder so, manch nix, eigentlich sollte auch wie gesagt eigentlich
sollte auch in den Browser off gehen, ah, ok wir machen das auf, geht das zu, jetzt
funktioniert es wahrscheinlich, ich mach das in Chrome auf, vielleicht hat das ja ein
Bug im Firefox oder so, ja das hat ein Bug im Firefox, irgendwas funktioniert mit dem
Firefox nicht, na geil, lull, also prinzipiell sollte es so aussehen, man hat dann ein Web,
man hat dann ein Web Interface wo man Windows, Command Bra, wo man draufklicken kann und
kriegt dann Overlays und das kann man natürlich auch vom zweiten Rechner aus machen und sowas,
ja oder man kann es natürlich auch vom Shortcut machen und sowas in der Richtung, so und jetzt
zeige ich euch nochmal was, was nämlich auch viel schöner ist in der zweiten Version
jetzt als in der ersten, nee im Chrome gehts ja, im Firefox gehts nicht, Eats, so, wir
ziehen jetzt nochmal ein neues Name rein, weil dann sieht man das wunderbar, also hier
haben wir keine Ahnung, Debated PLG, zack, track and drop, man kann jetzt hier sagen,
favorisieren das ganze, dass es immer vorne steht, wie gesagt Text to Speech oder sonst
was vorlesen, jetzt mache ich mal das, jetzt switche ich mal von Dark Seam zu Light Seam
und es sieht auch immer noch cool aus, ja, das ist viel besser als in der ersten Version
des Web Interfaces, das macht richtig was her, achso der Button hier macht übrigens
noch nix, also kann man jetzt jeder das verwenden was er will und was halt cool ist, dass man
das reintracken, droppen kann, uploaden und der speichert das dann, ich zeig es euch mal,
der speichert das dann hier in einem Content Ordner, als jeweils 1, 2, 3, 4 bla bla bla
wie auch immer die Datei heißt und hat hier eine SQLite Datenbank, woraus sich die ganzen
Informationen von den Bildchen drin speichert, das heißt nämlich auch, das ist super einfach
zu kopieren, also sprich, wenn ich das auf einem Rechner eingerichtet habe, da kann
ich einfach den Ordner nehmen und rüber kopieren auf dem zweiten Rechner und es funktioniert,
oder aber, und das müssen wir nämlich auch noch in einem der nächsten Streams machen,
einfach so ein billig Installer, das einzige was destürzt ist der Abstand zwischen dem
Button oben rechts, ja ich lade es auf GitHub wieder hoch, dann kannst du natürlich dann
ein Pullequest, ein Rechner für den Abstand, wir können den Abstand auch verringern, ach
ja, das CSS ist jetzt auch viel ordentlicher, guck mal, wir haben hier, machen wir mal kurz,
wie komme ich jetzt in den Solution Explorer rein, wenn man sich jetzt mal das CSS anguckt,
na guck mal, das ist viel ordentlicher Leute und da haben wir jetzt sowas wie hier NAV,
die Navigationsbar und da haben wir irgendwo auch so einen, wobei ich glaube den habe ich
gar nicht, ich glaube es gibt einfach nur einen normalen Button, der halt so ist, wie
der Button eben ist, guck mal die Navigationsleiste an, Button, nö die Button haben keine extra
ID, könnte man machen, man könnte die Button, den Abstand der Button oben noch ein bisschen
ändern, aber das ist jetzt erstmal das kleinste Problem, was ich dabei habe und auch kein
Inline CSS mehr, Multi-Upload fehlt, ich weiß gar nicht ob ich Multi-Upload haben will,
man muss ja, man möchte ja noch was dazu eingeben, wenn ich jetzt Multi-Upload mache,
dann hätte ich jetzt hier quasi, wie will man das machen, dann hätte man jetzt hier
quasi 14 Bilder oder so drinne und dann kannst du nur für ein Bild Text und Beschreibung
angeben oder so, was natürlich ziemlich blöd ist, das heißt es bleibt wahrscheinlich
erstmal bei einfachem Upload, man braucht ja auch nicht so viel, ich meine da macht
man sich 15 Bildchen rein und gut ist, so und jetzt probiere ich gerade nochmal ob das ganze
nicht vielleicht daran lag, dass ich mit dem falschen Browser gemacht habe, wir machen
das jetzt nochmal auf 5001 und die Form machen wir auch wieder auf 5001, 5001 jawoll, starten
wir das ganze, jetzt geht mal wieder kein Browser auf, ok, 5001, ja das lag da, FireFox,
frag mich nicht, komm wir gucken mal was der FireFox hier Probleme hat, warum es dem FireFox
nicht geht, ja und auch noch was zu der ganzen Geschichte von wegen Anti-Cheat, man muss
ja dazu sagen, ja natürlich könnte da irgendwie ein Anti-Cheat Zeug drauf anspringen, aber
ein Anti-Cheat könnte auch auf 999 andere Sachen anspringen, was es so gibt, ich meine
es hat ja alles irgendwie, weiß nicht ein Overlay, sondern halt irgendwie was was im
Hintergrund läuft, was im Hintergrund irgendwas macht, sei es ein Viren-Scanner im Hintergrund,
sei es irgendwie was ich encode im Hintergrund, das kann theoretisch auf alles anspringen,
warum sollte das gerade auf was anspringen, was ein Fenster mit einem Bild anzeigt, ich
meine Fenster mit einem Bild anzeigen und selbst wenn es darauf anspringt, da müssen
sie ja immer noch irgendwie, was da dran jetzt quasi böse ist, ist es ja nicht, also ich
würde das komplett bedenkenlos in jedem Game einsetzen, das ist auch das was ich vor hab
und wir haben ja auch mal im Stream was, warte mal, wir haben ja auch mal ein Tool gebastelt
wo man im Hintergrund Screenshots machen kann und dann Texterkennung drauf, das hab ich
für den MMO, ja das ist kaputt im Firefox, das hab ich für den MMO gemacht, dass ich
mitkriege wenn was in Marketplace kommt und das ist deutlich näher dran, da nennen wir
es mal Cheaten, das hat ja mit Cheaten überhaupt nichts zu tun, das ist einfach nur eine Hilfe
für Streamer, das ist quasi ein gepimptes Stream Deck oder sowas, bloß ohne Hardware
dran und wir können auch so viele Dinge einbauen, wir können eine Stream Deck Unterstützung
machen, wir können eine RGB Tastatur Unterstützung machen, alle möglichen Dinge, so jetzt müssen
wir mal in die, müssen wir mal gucken was Firefox dagegen hat, connected, error, event
is not defined, ok, was genau hat Firefox, das ist ja mal eine absolut nichts sagende
Fehlermeldung mit der Firefox, Chrome juckt das überhaupt nicht, event is not defined,
welches Event, wahrscheinlich das Event für Click, Click Event is not defined, immer wenn
ich da drauf klicke, ok wir gucken uns mal das Click Event gleich an, hier im Chrome ist
überhaupt kein Problem, funktioniert einfach, aber Firefox spakt rum, guck mal man sieht
auch im Firefox, im Firefox prinzipiell funktioniert es, die sind alle an diesen Message Hub connected,
also sprich wenn ich im Chrome klicke geht es hier im Firefox auch an und auf dem zweiten
Rechner geht es auch an und das Bild wird angezeigt, aber im Firefox selbst klicken
ist irgendwie kaputt, also muss es ja irgendwie um das Click Event gehen, also gucken wir
mal, hier Click, Moment ich bin falsch, da, Click, hier das da vielleicht, hat er damit
irgendwelche Schmerzen, ich mein, warum sollte er da mit Schmerzen haben, ok der hat da mit
Schmerzen, der hat da mit Schmerzen das hier und das hier Event drinne steht, wobei das
ziemlich behindert ist, weil ich brauch ja das Event an der Stelle, du hast mir ein Whisper
geschrieben, ich hab's gesehen ja, muss ich mir später angucken, was kannst du aus einem
interaktiven Film ein interaktives Spiel erstellen, da reicht beim Prane gerade nicht dazu, ja
UGS Line 6, das bringt mir nix, hallo MrRoxas, das ist das Computer View Source Code drinne,
so, wir machen einfach mal das Event weg an der Stelle, wir machen jetzt einfach mal das
Event weg, weil beim mittleren Maustaste funktioniert jetzt das gleiche Effekt, da erinnern wir
das hier nochmal drinne auf, Moment wie hieß das, ich kann mir immer meine eigenen Methoden
Namen nicht merken, Toggle, Toggle hieß das, wo ist es denn, ja, machen wir hier mal Event
weg, vielleicht geht's jetzt ja, Eats funktioniert, aber FireFox, wisst ihr eigentlich dachte
ich das ist Geschichte, dass sich quasi so Standard CSS und JavaScript Zeug sich zwischen
Browser so sehr unterscheidet, warum kann ich eigentlich im Chrome das Bild anklicken
und alles ist gut und im FireFox klicke ich, übrigens das funktioniert es, aber im FireFox
klicke ich das Bild an und er markiert das irgendwie, was ist das denn, warum markiert
er das Bild, wenn ich da drauf klicke, hä, weil ihr seht ja, wenn ich unten hin klicke
ist es wieder weg, das soll mal einer verstehen, gut, aber jetzt kümmern wir uns mal ein bisschen
um das Text to Speech, Sache für die nervige Frage, Black Ops 4 kommt schon, ach so, ja,
vielleicht nachher, wie gesagt ich hab heute den ganzen Tag Black Ops gespielt, wir müssen
mal gucken, gib mal das Event Objekt in der Konsole, ne es funktioniert doch, es funktioniert
doch, es ist ja alles gut, geht wieder, das einzige was nicht funktioniert ist, warum er
das markiert, ich weiß es nicht, ich brauch das Event eh nicht an der Stelle, ich dachte
nur vielleicht falls ich es brauche übergebe ich es mal, aber jetzt geht's ja, was ich
nicht check ist warum das ganze markiert wird, ich hab keinen Schimmer warum es selectet
wird, Black Ops 4 scheint wieder gut zu sein, ja ich finde es, also heute ging es mir schon
mehr auf den Sack als gestern, Style Focus, Focus Sable, sowas gibt es, ok, gucken wir
mal, ja, was, Focus, ne gibt es nicht, es gibt Select irgendwas, User Select gibt es,
aber wenn ich User Select auf Falls mache, weiß ich nicht ob ich Click Events kriege,
juckt nicht, oder ist es vielleicht das Bild was da drinnen selectet wird, das Image vielleicht
User Select, ne auf was muss man es stellen, none, none, ach was, was ich, CSS Leute ich
klicke Anfälle, das ist so, hä, warum selectet er das, was ist das, und das ist auch nicht
die Hinterfarbe, Hintergrundfarbe, der selectet das wirklich, keine Ahnung, Max wenn dich
an die December
das ist doch demnächst irgendwie eins zwei wochen oktober 19 oktober genau sehr
sehr nice ja ja das das werden wir auf jeden fall uns angucken da bin ich mal
gespannt darauf aber das ist halt auch wieder so ein umfangreiches game wo man
es richtig verkacken kann also das game hat auf jeden fall
potentiale und ich freue mich dass es mal wieder ein game quasi im modernen
deutschland map mit modernen setting
was ein live stream läuft gerade am usch bei nachher mal angucken aber wisst
ja ich also mir sagt jetzt was mir sagt der hersteller auch nix was haben die
denn sonst noch sonst noch gemacht
sagt mir alles nix painkiller kann ich noch aber auch schon uralt das von 2003
oder so ansonsten also sprich das ist ja wohl irgendwie in den hersteller der
noch nix irgendwie rausgebracht hat wirklich oder get even was geht ihm
sagt mir überhaupt nix mix sehen horror game oder so ich weiß nicht also ich bin
da skeptisch das sieht schon geil aus und auch was man im vorfeld gesehen hat
ist ja nice das scenario gefällt mir persönlich auch viel viel besser als
zweiter weltkrieg zweiter weltkrieg habe ich eigentlich überhaupt keinen bock
drauf aber nun ja so wie das so ist ich bin ja mittlerweile immer misstrauisch
nice science and technology ja es gibt kein wie hieß es vorher creative creative
gibt es nicht mehr es gibt jetzt switch just chatting oder so was gibt es jetzt
dass da können die grills in die kamera gucken mit ausschnitt früher gab es der
ihl und ihl gibt es nicht mehr ihl ist jetzt ist jetzt just just chatting ist
das jetzt und programming und art ist jetzt creative ist jetzt aufgeteilt in
art und science and technology
ja so sieht es aus max wenn man wischer eins anschaut hätte man nie mit wischer
drei gerechnet du vergisst dass zwischen eins und drei noch was gekommen ist
zwischen eins und drei kann nämlich wischer zwei und wischer zwei war schon
super gelb und wischer eins war auch ein richtig gutes gelb wischer zwei waren
absolut top game und wischer drei war noch mal richtig richtig geil so aber
eigentlich wollten wir uns jetzt ein bisschen um text to speech kümmern also
windows text also windows text to speech ist schon mal easy das kriegen wir hin
ich mache mal das neue meme tool wieder zu das werde ich noch ein bisschen
verfeinern und dann lade ich das ganze auf github hoch und ich denke das ist
dann auch mal in der qualität wo man sagen kann da können da können wir mal
was kann man installer draus machen können das auch mal releasen das ganze
so und jetzt machen wir text to speech jetzt machen wir erst mal das alte
meme tool an dass ich
bildchen ab zum einblenden
gut funktioniert wieder so ja installer installer brauchen wir weil
das ist windows das ist leider so es ist super schwierig für windows
programme zu basteln die quasi alles in einer datei drinne haben also dass du
nur eine exe kriegst und und das ist das ist gar nicht so einfach dass was du
noch am ehesten machen kannst ist halt wenn es irgendwie dort netting ist
versuchen da alles rein zu linken aber da hört spätestens hört an vielen
stellen relativ schnell auf du könntest in den self extracting zipp oder so was
machen was im endeffekt auch nur installer ist der ist dann halt
irgendwo hin kopiert user select für mozilla mozilla user select nan das
sollte eigentlich nicht mehr also diese wenn er prefix sollte man eigentlich
nicht mehr brauchen aber das probieren wir probieren wir später aus
ähm was wollte ich jetzt sagen voll vergessen
konfused ob ich das jetzt wieder auf dem zweiten rechner ankriege
ab funktioniert
so was habe ich jetzt überlesen hier japanische stimme jesse baro aber das
muss man lizenzieren lizenzieren ist doof ja und mit installer meine ich
übrigens keinen mit assistent sondern so was was eigentlich das ding einfach
nur irgendwo hin entpackt und ab und zu halt auch mal anzeigt wenn es ein update
gibt also da gibt es da gibt es nämlich für net programme was ganz praktisches
nämlich heißt das glaube ich was da das ist eigentlich total einfach da
klickst du das programm an sagst einmal starten und es ist installiert und hat
auch eine benachrichtigung für updates und sowas ok also das ist baro hat uns
was geschickt für
ach tatsächlich geht das nur mit mit mit prefix ok dass sie baro hat uns
irgendwas für wieb stimme geschickt gucken wir mal müssen wir aber gleich
mal sagen ob es laut genug ist weil wir jetzt schon text to speech ausprobieren
müssen wir halt auch gucken also was haben wir hier japanis
was was für was soll ich für eine sprecherin auswählen
haruka so ok und dann sagen wir jetzt mal omega lull das muss man glaube ich
anders schreiben wobei ich glaube wörter mit lul drinne ist ist für ist für
japaner nix
warum programmierst du mit sie scharf weil es mir gefällt oder willst du
oder willst du darauf raus was war was für mich die vorteile dabei sind
das kann ich das kann ich dir erzählen ansonsten einfach weil es mir weil es
mein lieblingssprache ist probieren mal den englischen text jebaited
overrated outdated nao jebaited ihr müsst mal sagen ob es laut genug ist was
soll ich ausprobieren omega röhrer hört man das überhaupt nicht laut genug
ich habe eine idee vielleicht vielleicht so
warte ein bisschen lauter ok
das funktioniert nicht das funktioniert nicht schlecht ok
ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok oh schad ich mir fällt auch da müssen wir aufpassen
da da müssen wir aufpassen wenn man nach so was sucht auch wenn es vollkommen
legitime suche ist man weiß nie auf welchen seiten man raus kommt wenn man
da jetzt draufklickt. Vielleicht komme ich gleich mal auf am Watchporn oder sowas raus, man weiß das nie, wenn man da so was sucht.
Achso ja genau, ich wollte noch was zu... warum ich C-Sharp verwende. Also ich muss sagen, an sich...
Also hauptsächlich die Grundlage, weil es die Sprache ist, die mir am besten gefällt, aber der Vorteil von C-Sharp finde ich ist eindeutig, dass die
Werkzeuge drum herum fallen, vor allem wenn man das für Windows entwickelt und wir entwickeln das ja in dem Fall für ja eigentlich...
Wobei noch nicht mal Windows-only, theoretisch läuft das auch überall anders, wenn man halt eine ordentliche Oberfläche machen würde.
Aber nachdem wir eh Windows-only programmieren, kann man halt auch die Vorteile davon nutzen, nämlich dass unter Windows die ganze.NET-Geschichte halt super Tools hat, sowas wie Visual Studio oder
alle möglichen Sachen, die es drum herum gibt, das macht es einfach angenehm damit etwas zu entwickeln.
Außerdem ist viel eingebaut schon und es ist halt relativ einfach, damit auch kompliziertere Sachen hinzukriegen.
Und ich finde auch, wenn man Windows-Sachen machen will, sowohl Web-Anwendungen als auch Desktop-Anwendungen oder Konsolen-Anwendungen oder sowas,
und jetzt mit.NET Core ja auch für andere Betriebssysteme, leider noch ohne GUI, vielleicht kommt das ja noch irgendwann mal,
finde ich ist das aktuell so mit eines der besten Sachen zum Einsteigen.
Ja, da kann man sich... Was heißt das? Ich wollte gerade sagen, man kann sich da drüber streiten.
Eigentlich kann man sich da nicht gar nicht drüber streiten, das hat jedes seine Vor- und Nachteile.
Ich finde es zum Beispiel deutlich angenehmer in C-Sharp was zu machen als in C++, wenn es aber letztendlich auf irgendwelche Low-Level-Geschichten ankommt
oder wenn du halt irgendwas wie Qt verwenden willst, was es nur für C++ gescheit gibt, dann spricht ja auch nichts dagegen, was in C++ zu machen.
Der Sebaro schickt mir Sachen. Kann ich das aufmachen, ohne dass da irgendwas passiert?
Wir brauchen halt eine... Wir brauchen eine Seite, die ein gescheiter API hat, alles andere bringt nichts. Wir müssen... Okay, wir suchen uns mal weiter.
Was gibt es denn da alles? Ich habe ja vor einer Weile schon mal gesucht und ich hatte eine Seite, die war gar nicht so schlecht.
Die war zwar komplett in Japanisch, aber es gab eine API, die wir verwenden konnten und die Sprecherinnen und Sprecher klang auch gut.
Ich weiß bloß nicht mehr, wie das Ganze hieß.
Ich weiß bloß nicht mehr, wie das Ganze hieß. Wie hieß das denn?
Wie hieß der Grams denn? Vielleicht habe ich das irgendwie... Ich muss mal suchen, ob ich mir das irgendwo aufgeschrieben habe.
Ich komme mal in meinen Notes, ob ich das irgendwo aufgeschrieben habe. TTS... TTS... Memeboard... TTS... Voice Text... Voice Text hieß das.
TTS... Voice Text... Ah ja, das da, genau. Man versteht leider nichts, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem dabei.
Aber es sieht schon mal richtig nach der richtigen Seite aus, wenn man eine schöne Web Text-to-Speech Engine sucht.
Dann sieht das schon mal richtig gut für aus. So, wen nehmen wir denn mal?
Wen wollen wir haben? Risa, Erika, Hikari, Sayaka, Haruka, Misaki. Haruka nehmen wir jetzt mal.
Haruka nehmen wir jetzt mal. Okay. O, N, E, G, A, L, U, L. Und die haben auch eine API. Das Problem dabei, das wird witzig, das kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen.
Das Problem ist, die API, da müssen wir uns anmelden für und die Seite ist komplett in Japanisch.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie versuchen, den API hier auf Japanisch zu generieren, wenn das funktioniert.
Was programmierst du denn da? Wir basteln ein Overlay-Programm, also womit man sich nie ein Bildchen am Prinzip, jedes Bild und animierte Gifts als Overlay anzeigen lassen kann.
Ohne aber, dass man, dass die Einfluss haben auf das andere Programm, guckst, kann ich durchklicken und sowas.
Das heißt, das kann ich als Overlay, wenn ich streame oder für YouTube-Videos oder sowas verwenden und einfach einplanten zwischendurch.
Okay, äh, Mikro oder was auch immer das heißt, keine Ahnung. Nehmt ihr einen Insta-, ich will ja nichts übersetzen, ich will ja Text-to-Speech haben, das ist ja gerade der Witz daran.
Äh, und wieso machst du bei YouTube nicht mal so viele Videos? Ich mache auf, weil mir die Plattform ziemlich auf den Sack geht.
Omega Little.
Ne, das war übrigens nicht die Stimme von Haruka, ähm, weil mir YouTube als Plattform ziemlich auf den Kicks geht und einfach weil mir auch die Games gefehlt haben, die mir Spaß gemacht haben, die sich geeignet haben.
Sollen wir mal gucken, wie sich das hier anhört.
O-M-E-D-A-L-U-L
Okay, das hört sich schon mal besser an, das hört sich schon mal besser an. Aber das mit dem Lul haben sie nicht so ganz. Das mit dem Lul funktioniert nicht, das ist einfach nichts für...
Was heißt das hier alles? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Okay, wir versuchen uns jetzt mal eine AP-Key zu generieren auf Japanisch.
Wie gut kennst du dich mit C-Sharp aus? Ich würde sagen, ganz gut.
Also ich hab damit schon einige Dinge gemacht. Und hatte im Stream mit ein paar Sachen rumgespielt schon, aber da sieht man es eigentlich, dass ich zumindest, was das Framework angeht, eigentlich ganz gut durchblicke.
Halt bei neuen Sachen, wo ich letztens hier mit ASP angefangen habe. Natürlich muss man sich da ein bisschen einarbeiten, aber nach einer Weile geht es da wieder.
Hat Chrome nicht in den Translate integriert? Ja, das bringt mir ja nichts.
Okay, das bringt mir ja nichts. Das bringt mir nichts. Ich will ja, dass man...
Sag mal, rockelt das oder gehört das zu dieser komischen Musik dabei?
What the fuck?
Was zum Teufel geht mit meinem Browser ab?
Ich glaube, das liegt dann jetzt im Stream.
Chillstep Radio, machen wir irgendwas in der Richtung.
Geht doch. Keine Ahnung, das Stream von denen ist gerade irgendwie abgespackt.
Okay, jetzt gucken, ob das mit R-U-R, aber das geht glaube ich auch nicht.
O-M-E-G-A-R-U-R
Nein, das klappt nicht. Aber wir müssen uns jetzt mal einen Api-Key generieren für diese komische japanische Text-to-Speech-Seite.
Das ist dumm. Aber ich meine, letztendlich kann sich ja jeder selbst aussuchen, was der sagt. Man kann ja den Text eintragen.
Es ist eigentlich, muss sich halt jeder selbst überlegen, der es dann verwendet, was er da für einen Text reinschreibt.
Ich meine, das mit Omega-0 war jetzt ja eigentlich nur ein Test zum Ausprobieren.
So. So, wie kann man uns auf der Seite jetzt irgendwelche Api-Key generieren? Das wird schlimm.
Wir machen das mal von unserer Linux-VM aus. Wir machen das mal von unserer Linux-VM aus.
Wer weiß, auf welchen japanischen Seiten ich da rumsausen muss.
Das ist mir lieber. Das ist mir lieber, das aus Linux auszumachen.
Also, wie ist das Ding? Voice-Text-Api.
So. Wenn man das jetzt so richtig schreibt, findet man es auch. Voice-Text-Api.
So. Also übrigens, falls ich was vergessen habe zu beantworten, ihr könnt es da nochmal reinschreiben. Ich sehe das gerade nicht alles.
Rechtsklick übersetzen. Ja, aber das bringt mir doch nichts. Ich will doch in meinem Programm einen Text-to-Speech drin haben.
Das heißt, ich brauche irgendeinen Service, der für mich Text-to-Speech macht.
Am besten fällt dann irgendein Waff oder so was hinten raus oder ein MP3 oder sonst was, was ich mir speichern kann und immer abspielen, wenn der User auf den Knopf drückt.
Also, zum Beispiel, ich zeige euch das jetzt mal, dass man das auch versteht, was ich da letztendlich vorhabe.
Wenn wir hier das Web-Interface haben, das ist übrigens noch das alte Tool. Gehen wir auf das Web-Interface.
Dann haben wir hier zum Beispiel einen Knopf für Text-to-Speech. Dann klickt man drauf und dann sagt er Omega-Lol.
Ich will aber, dass er nicht Omega-Lol sagt in dem Fall, sondern jeden beliebigen Text.
Und halt auch nicht nur mit der Windows die Fault-Stimme.
Deswegen brauchen wir, wir brauchen halt verschiedene Stimmen dafür.
Ich hätte einmal gerne so eine richtig schöne Anime-Weep-Stimme, dann am besten noch irgendeine russische Stimme oder sowas.
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung, irgendwas markantes halt, dass du auch ein paar lustige Effekte machen kannst.
Weil Windows Standard-Stimme einfach dumm klingt.
Ach, er meint, dass ich die Seite übersetzen soll.
Ach, er meint, dass ich die Seite übersetzen soll. Oh, das ist Pick-Prain.
Ach so, kann man das so machen. Rechtsklick-Translate, tatsächlich.
Das ist immer wie ich keine Ahnung davon eigentlich habe, dass das überhaupt funktioniert.
Okay, das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Translate to English, Name, Mail-Adress, Phone-Number, ja ganz bestimmt.
Company-Department, ja wir machen das.
Okay, wir brauchen eine Fake-E-Mail-Adresse.
Gibt es da, was, was, was gibt es da Schönes?
Wegwerfe-E-Mail.de, das klingt auch gut.
Oder Beyond.de, Tempere-Mail.
Tempere-Mail.
Die Seite sieht aus wie von 1995.
Ten-Minute-Mail.
Moin, Jorah, out.
Spam, WC, was ist da alles?
Ten-Minute-Mail klingt gut.
Ich probiere jetzt einfach mal was durch, es könnte ja auch sein, dass die Anbieter geblockt haben oder so.
Okay, Ten-Minute-Mail geht schon mal irgendwie nicht auf.
Irgendjemand hat am Anfang gefragt, was das für ein Desktop ist.
Ist derjenige noch da?
Wollte wissen, was das für eine E3-Version ist oder sowas, ne?
Ist derjenige noch am Start? Weil da kann ich ein bisschen zeigen gleich noch.
Okay, Ten-Minute-Mail ist...
Die braucht wahrscheinlich Ten-Minutes, bis sie aufgeht oder so.
Also was hat eben noch einer gesagt?
SpamWC, das ist ein, das hat schon mal ein guter Name, muss ich sagen.
Ups.
Moin, Sgt. Neo.
SpamWC.de, wegwerf E-Mail. Oh ja, das ist gut, das brauchen wir jetzt.
One-Time-Mail-Address.
Lul, perfekt.
Admin, Lul, in 2K18, Mama.
Autovervollständigung, beste.
Ähm, was, was machen wir das da für eine Weeb-TTS?
Was wurde, was wurde heute schon alles geschafft?
Ne, ich habe jetzt angefangen, ich habe die, das neue Interface vom Memetool 2.0 gezeigt.
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass es Passwörter waren, ich glaube eher, dass es Usernames waren.
Es liegen derzeit keine E-Mails vor.
Okay, und wie kann man, wie kann man das jetzt, refrescht man jetzt ein?
Was?
Wie funktioniert dieses komische Ding?
Ach, muss man da jedes Mal auf Cent drücken, das ist ja ein bisschen komisch.
Ach, muss man da jedes Mal auf Cent drücken, das ist, ah ja, okay.
Ähm, gut, dann melden wir uns jetzt mal mit, was ist das eigentlich für eine Adresse?
Sieht so, es ist ziemlich random, aber es ist auch gut, dass es random ist, dann haben sie es wahrscheinlich nicht geplockt.
Okay, Name, Mail, äh, wenn ich da jetzt reinklicke, kommt dann die Autovervollständigung für die Telefonnummer.
Nummer so, blöd gefragt, kann man die Autovervollständigung irgendwie löschen oder so?
Wie löscht man das im Chrome?
Mocker ist.
Wie löscht man das?
Genau.
Okay.
Also irgendwo gibt es hier einen löschen Knopf.
Okay, wenn es in der History Clear drinne ist.
Passwords, Autofill Formdata, Hosted App, alles weg.
All time, bam.
Die Seite war kaputt.
Ha, Autovervollständigung ist weg.
Autovervollständigung ist weg. Okay, ich kann jetzt Telefonnummerfeld klicken.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es optional ist, das war aber Autovervollständigung vom Chrome.
Also sprich, wenn ich hier reingeklickt hätte und ich mal irgendwo in einem Form meine echte Telefonnummer eingetragen hätte, hätte es jetzt hier auch vervollständigt, das muss ja nicht unbedingt sein.
Department, Application Purpose, alles, Android, iOS, Web Application, Confirm.
Vielleicht darf man das nicht mit Übersetzen machen.
Ha, hat funktioniert. Hat funktioniert, man darf das bloß nicht mit Übersetzen machen. Welche Knöpfe sind was?
Ich stecke da jetzt einfach mal drauf. Perfekt. Gut. Mal gucken, ob ich jetzt einen Key gekriegt habe.
Äh, wie kann ich jetzt die E-Mail anzeigen lassen? Das kann doch nicht die E-Mail sein, oder? Ich meine, Japanisch sieht schon mal, sieht schon mal aus.
Aber muss ich vielleicht mein Ad-Blog machen? Nö.
Wie? Wie? What the fuck? Was ist das für eine Kackseite?
Hä? Die E-Mail stand hier eben unten da. Aber halt, als, keine Ahnung, wir nehmen die E-Mail jetzt.
Wir nehmen jetzt was anderes. Das ist dumm, das funktioniert nicht. Kann doch nicht sein, das ist, wie kann man so eine Seite so schwierig zu benutzen machen? So, next.
Neuer Key, zack, zack, zack, web. So, wir nehmen jetzt das hier. Das sieht, das sieht so billig aus, wie von 1995, das funktioniert bestimmt gut.
Ah, so. Wahrscheinlich Face, ah, ich muss bestimmt die, die, ähm, das ist bestimmt, äh, Terms of Service Accepten.
Okay. Alter, warum ist das so kompliziert? Nice, da ist es, Anzeigen. Ist das mal ein AP-Key?
Seite übersetzen. Übersetzt nicht, auch gut. Ähm, okay, wir machen jetzt Google Translate. Äh, Google Translate.
Oh Mann, das ist ein Akt, oder? Das ist ein Akt von so einer japanischen Seite, einen AP-Key zu kriegen.
Japanisch? Und danach gibt es was? Yawanisch? Ja, Yawanisch? Hat das was mit, oh Gott, nein.
Dann lieber Japanisch, bevor es Yawa-ish ist. Okay, machen wir mal Englisch.
Dear Aster Aster Aster Aster Aster, welcome to your AP-Key. Ist sehr schön, wir haben das AP-Key. Sehr, sehr nice. Den brauchen wir.
aber irgendwie kopieren
perfekt funktioniert
ok
jawoll
so machen wir das
karl blablabla
ok probiert ihr das deswegen machen wir das von linux aus so was, da ist nämlich das viel einfacher
ok wir können jetzt den speaker auswählen, den text
wir machen jetzt mal einen anderen text, wir machen jetzt mal einen text
monkaS
your api key
und dann gucken wir mal ob das einfach funktioniert
output
testwaff
hat nicht funktioniert
ok dann funktioniert das mit your api key doch so nicht
sondern wahrscheinlich müssen wir
komm wir schreiben den api key jetzt einfach zweimal hin, wer weiß was die japaner sich dabei
gedacht haben
api key liegt ja, ganz ganz super geheimer api key
ja das ist geil, das ist geil
hört euch an das ist geil
beste
ich muss lauter machen
das ist gut
so muss das sein
so wir machen noch ein lehrzeichen dazwischen, da klingt es bestimmt noch besser
jetzt öffnen wir das mal hinten dran
monkaS, oh das ist gut, das ist nice
wir müssen vlc ein bisschen leiser machen
zu besteuert ein bisschen
ich frage mich ja warum leute solche apis umsonst anbieten, ich vermute mal
weil also viele services die apis umsonst haben, entweder ist das halt so
komplett open sourcing oder wenn das ein service ist der halt auch
pay apis hat
dass die es entweder bestrengen auf so und so viel aufrufen, was die hier letztendlich
auch machen werden
wenn wir uns jetzt die japanischen terms of services durchlesen wünschen, ist da
bestimmt drinne, quasi ab so und so viel aufrufen kostet es was
oder aber um werbung zu machen für ihre volle api, dass das eben nur ein teil davon ist
so perfekt
ich finde das ist übelst nice
was war das, das ist übelst nice, monkaS
monkaS
richtig der weebshit
rausgetappt
was haben wir denn für optionen, was gibt es denn da noch
haben die sowas wie api docs, das brauchen wir
und das ganze jetzt bitte auf englisch
was sind das, text to speech, speaker
speaker list
ok wir haben anzubieten
haruka
und hikari, dann haben wir noch, was zum teufel, was
was
ein wilder bär
alter die japaner
und unsanta
was zum teufel
komm wir müssen uns vor uns den bär mal anhören
komm wir hören uns den bär jetzt mal an
monkaS
alter
ok
wie hört sich denn
ok, hikari haben wir jetzt, wie hört sich denn
haruka an
ich hör da keinen unterschied, hört ihr da einen unterschied
das war jetzt haruka und jetzt kommt noch mal
hikari
monkaS
das ist exakt die gleiche stimme
santa, santa, wollen wir noch mal santa machen leute
santa, ok
monkaS
ok, der bär ist besser, der bär ist besser
das ist nicht so toll, der bär ist aber am besten
das hört sich überhaupt nicht nach santa an, warum ist das santa
keine ahnung, vielleicht sollten wir, ich hab noch ne idee
vielleicht sollten wir
vielleicht sollten wir nach monka einen punkt machen, das ist quasi, sieht besser an
so monkaS
monkaS
das ist noch besser oder
ok
aber wisst ihr was ich gerade gesehen hab
man kann hier noch ein emotion level eintragen
also wahrscheinlich wie fröhlich sie sich anhören oder sowas bei monkaS
ach nee, ah nee, man muss erstmal die emotion auswählen
emotion happy, ah wir machen happy, wir machen monkaS mein ultra happy
happiness
und emotion level
emotion level
4, also wir machen jetzt den happiest monkaS den es irgendwie gibt
das ist geil
das ist geil, das muss ich unbedingt einbauen, das wird der hit
ich sag euch, das wird das angesagteste twitch tool aller Zeiten
wenn da sowas drin ist, da gehen die leute drauf ab
mach das mal mit dem bär
moment, wie war das mit dem bär noch
komplett für den arsch eigentlich
ok, wir müssen jetzt nochmal den typ anhören
show
show, hauen wir uns mal show an
show kann keine emotions
ah ok, emotions können nur
takeru, ist takeru ein kerl, ok takeru
japanische text to speech
da nee, wir bleiben bei hikari, hikari ist am besten
hikari, beste
ok jetzt müssen wir, wie der aufruf aussieht, jetzt müssen wir diesen aufruf nochmal in z sharp nachbasteln
aber die ist toll oder
wie ist das anhört
ok wir brauchen noch mal etwas anderes
habt ihr noch eine gute idee, was wir mal als text verwenden könnten
ok wir machen hier auch nochmal
mal gucken wie es das hier mit anhört
what
das hat ja mit dem original jetzt aber nichts zu tun oder
was zum teufel
ist das dein linux rise
wenn man es so nennen mag
das ist i3, ach stimmt, ja irgendjemand wollte vorher wissen was das ist
das ist i3 gaps
mit statusleiste und so
also wenn du, also wirklich krass gerized ist das jetzt nicht
das ist genau ein terminal mit einem chrome browser hier und mit einem i3
und ein paar desktops
und wechselt in hintergrundbildern
aber ich finde es sieht ganz nice aus für selbstgemacht
was haben die eigentlich
ok man darf, guck mal, deswegen die api
ist bestimmt begrenzt weil
also da gibt es bestimmt eine kostenpflichtige api version davon
weil die kostenlose api kann plus maximal 200 zeichen
was reicht für das normale zeug
und die haben auch nur
japanische sprecher wie es aussieht
fertig ist die sharp library, die braucht man nicht wirklich dafür aber
man weiß ja nicht, vielleicht kann man noch mehr sprecher verwenden
gucken wir da mal rein was die für sprecher zur auswahl haben
speaker
ne haben auch nur die
aber für japanischen text to speech ist das toll
das heißt wenn irgendjemand quasi jetzt im webinterface ein text eingibt und sagt er will die
weep text to speech version haben
dann wird das hier im hintergrund einmal ausgeführt
die waff datei wird gespeichert und dann einfach abgespielt
gibt doch bestimmt bessere kostenlose voice tools
ja wenn du mir eins sagst dann nehme ich das
also vor allem
vor allem was halt kostenlose mit einer ordentlichen api
ich hab bis jetzt keins, wenn du eins kennst
schieß los ja
wenn du die stimme noch höher haben willst kannst du auf pitch 100%
oh nee ich glaub dann hört sich irgendwann schon mal richtig beknackt an
aber ihr könnt es mal ausprobieren
da muss ich aber vorher mal ein bisschen leiser stellen
man weiß ja nie
oh pitch, pitch 100%
ah nee pitch ist schon 100%
pitch ist default 100% wir können das auf 200% stellen
was zum
alter
ok das funktioniert nur mit kurzen mit kurzen wörtern die sich für japanisch
eignen
wie wäre es mit google text to speech
ja kann google text to speech denn ordentliche
japanische also
interessante stimme also irgendwas was
meme charakter hat und was sich für
für twitch eignet und ist es kostenlos
google sperrt mich instant wenn ich den api key public auf auf github hoch
lade
hingegen ist den japanern wahrscheinlich wurscht es
ich mach nochmal einen ticken lauter
gut
aber nichtsdestotrotz
wir gucken jetzt mal wie wir das in die scharpe reinkriegen oder
oder wollen wir noch mal irgendwas ausprobieren
ja das bringt richtig was
emotions
emotions ja ok machen wir nochmal
machen wir nochmal unseren monkaS
wir machen jetzt sadness sadness sad monkaS machen wir jetzt
sadness und anger monkaS
und pitch den pitch mal wieder zurück
der pitch ist zu übertrieben
oh
deprimierender monkaS
feels bad man
so jetzt haben wir das ganze jetzt mit
verärgert monkaS
fast auch besser
aber ich muss sagen den happy
den happy monkaS ist der beste
ja das ist auch am besten
ok gucken wir mal wie wir das jetzt rüber kriegen
kopieren wir uns das ganze mal
nein das sollst du nicht auskommentieren
so ich scroll mal kurz den chat durch ob ich irgendwas
übersehen habe
ob die api ein rate limit hat wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich
also wenn das dann ganz viele leute verwenden
werden die mich wahrscheinlich blocken oder so
dann muss ich halt jeder seinen eigenen api key generieren
wer das verwenden will
dann reicht das
aber müssen wir mal gucken
erstellst du eigentlich manchmal ein uml für eigene projekte uml ist der
größte krab aller Zeiten
das ist vor allem das sinnloseste wozu brauche ich
das ist komplett
overrated einfach nur
ich weiß es gibt leute die schwören da drauf aber ich finde es total bescheuert
habe ich übersehen
gut
das habe ich noch nicht verwendet also müssen wir mal gucken
wie kriegen wir das jetzt runtergeladen
über so ein stack overflow
mal bemühen
download file how to download
webclient
also download ist ja easy
wobei wir wollen ja nicht download file haben sondern wir wollen
request hinschicken
mit mit unseren optionen und dann die antwort auslesen
gucken wir mal gucken wir uns mal die doko an
die
microsoft hilfe seiten sind meistens relativ gut
auch mit beispiel und sowas
webclient
so
brauchen wir alles nicht
brauchen im prinzip wahrscheinlich einfach nur url option oder so also so
habe ich zumindest die seite von denen verstanden dass man es einfach an die
url dranhängen kann
denke ich mal
es macht ein curl-d ist meistens mal ein url-parameter
natürlich haben sie dafür kein beispiel drin
probieren wir das mal aus ob man das einfach als url-parameter machen kann
zack bitte keine indische tastatur wieder
user und password müssen wir noch eintragen das müssen wir wahrscheinlich
das wahrscheinlich basic aus oder sowas das probieren wir mal aus
also quasi sowas da gucken ob das überhaupt funktioniert ich weiß gar nicht
wie der richtige aufruf davon jetzt ist
und dann sagen wir sowas wie hier
speaker
gleich davon überhaupt gleich als zeichen die url verwenden
was macht minus minus deba curl macht es in body ist es macht es einen post mit
einem
im body oder wie macht es was macht es eigentlich standardmäßig
mal kurz gucken
dass ich überhaupt weiß wie ich den kram zusammen bauen muss
b
minus d
hallo minus d zeigt mal die hilfe minus d an
b
minus d
was ist das für eine hilfe seite
was macht minus d
es kann jetzt sein dass es wieder so kompliziert zu finden ist
jose minus d
minus d ist
data
sense
ah
oh nee
an die url encode ja wunderbar doch das das ist kein ding das kriege ich gebacken
ok jetzt muss ich das ganz normal entkommen das dürfte eigentlich kein großer akt sein
mal gucken wie das funktioniert
einfach ja ich könnte auch weiherschlagen oder irgendwas anschmeißen
was link ist falsch
ah link ist
ja richtig link ist falsch
das ist falsch kopiert
bei nee eigentlich
für mehr stehen sie baro das kostet jetzt aber was bei denen
ok ne das funktioniert irgendwie anders
da muss jetzt erstmal eigentlich mal gucken wie man das funkt wie man das ordentlich macht
also mindestens wollen wir erstmal die url die url können wir erstmal setzen das wie geht denn das ja
ist
so und dann muss ich da jetzt irgendwas
ok das gestaltet sich glaube komplizierter als ich mir das vorgestellt habe den kram
unterzuladen
im endeffekt einfach nur die waffe speichern und dann gucken dass ich sie bei mir verwenden kann
da brauchen wir erstmal nicht es sei denn da stört sich dran
ok das ist nicht schlecht
das ist irgendwas fertig ist von dem
wann kommt die da in x-hook damit das auch in fullscreen klappt das machen wir nicht
weil das wahrscheinlich anti cheat wirklich triggert
heißt das ding wirklich so
tatsächlich heißt so
ach jetzt wirklich cool ja was sich alles gibt ok url encode also brauchen wir
kann uns das ganze mal abgucken die minimal variante ist ja quasi text gleich
das doch funktioniert bin ich echt mal gespannt was da rauskommt das ding noch nie verwendet
den ganzen schitt hier mal weg
ja ja
ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
toller
so was so was in der richtung da sieht man was er schickt das ist ganz gut da kann ich
es nämlich einfach abgucken
oder auch nicht na doch basic auth macht er
content time müssen wir setzen es ist ein post ok das muss man ja alles wissen
also machen wir einen post dahin
wann kommen die streams mit facecam
tja bei einer million youtube abos
moin komme gerade vom video was machst du gerade blick nicht durch
ich zeig sie euch mal also erstmal muss man sagen das machen wir schon eine weile hier
im stream ich bastel ein tool für twitch streamer wo man bilder als overlays verwenden kann also
wo man sich quasi overlay bildchen anzeigen lassen kann mit bisschen sinnlos animieren
und sowas in der richtung die halt einfach oben drüber sind und man kann durchklicken
und sowas also sprich die beeinflussen nix plus das tool kann seit neuestem auch text
to speech allerdings nur mit dem windows standard text to speech
so hört sich das an und nachdem der windows text to speech ziemlich dumm ist haben wir
gerade versucht ob wir nicht eine schöne weep variante von diesem text to speech hinkriegen
können das ganze hört sich dann so an und ich versuche gerade irgendwie diese komischen
japanischen text to speech service den sound abzurufen aber wir müssen demdinger dynamisch
text übergeben was der denn sprechen soll und wir brauchen dann als antwort eine waff
datei halt mit diesem text zu weep stimme das wollte ich erstmal gucken wie man das
überhaupt ordentlich runter lädt ja das machen wir gerade
ok wie setzt man hier content type
kommt da muss man da wirklich hätte extra setzen
das wenn man das ding überhaupt richtig content type
content type das ist ja sehr raw dieses ding gibt es gibt es gibt es keine ordentliche
keine ordentliche htp library für net wo man das nicht so nicht so viel von fuß machen
kann er überhaupt ein post machen wie macht man damit ein post also post data mit web
klein upload was or das ist wir das verwirrt mich das das ding wie verwendet man das gescheit
warum kann ich nicht sagen klein punkt post macht aber eine url hin bloß ein paar parameter
funktioniert ist das kompliziert upload data wollen nicht wirklich data upload wir wollen
eigentlich schon ein post machen kennt ihr mal noch ordentliche dotnet htp library mit
stack overflow triffen sind wir heute wieder ganz schön pur stack overflow triffen so
geht das also ok upload data da muss jetzt die japanische seite rein gut und da müssen
wir noch basic aus mit dem apk machen nur post so und data gibt jetzt was flurl punkt
eo ok gucken wir uns mal an hauptsache viele basmerz ja das sieht eigentlich schon mal
das sieht ja mal viel schöner aus als hat auch viele sterne hier guck mal das sieht
ja viel angenehmer zu verwenden aus als htp klein web klein ding da kannst du gar ganz
sogar aussetzen und sowas aber das ist schön aber wir probieren es mal rauszukriegen wie
das mit dem normalen htp klein machen würde gucken ob ich das irgendwie gebacken krieg
so also brauche ich hier viel eins als war speaker gleich wie ist die hikaru oder so hikari
speaker gleich hikari das ist das und text gleich bonkers so jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt
ob das irgendwie funktioniert unauthorized ok damit kann ich leben damit kann ich leben
das machen wir jetzt basic aus können wir noch machen aber nicht von hand sondern probieren
ob das ding das so unterstützt unauthorized ok so funktioniert es also schon mal net also
wie macht man basic aus klein das ding ist wirklich komplett handarbeit hätte ich gedacht
dass es so kompliziert ist ich muss das allen ernstes von hand machen also ich meine ich
weiß wie basic aus funktioniert das ist irgendwie denn das ist das ist username passwort und
dann irgendwie als base 64 oder sowas so wieder da ist die webseite eine asp.net plus javascript
meinst du die vom vom vom tool ja das ist du meinst die hier das ist asp.net core und
view gs omega lul noch kontakt zum friseur kaboom zum kaboom schon eine weile nicht mehr
als ein jahrhörn ein jahr her dass ich was von ihm gehört habe bzw was von mir gehört
hat mit fabian öfters täglich fast zwar nicht zwar nicht viel aber die fabian kenne
ich auch schon ewig so wie ok wie kriegt man das mit dem webclient jetzt gebacken das
kann so nicht sein basic or webclient
das not work es ist schön dass das ding credentials fällt aber wir probieren es jetzt trotzdem
mal so vielleicht funktioniert es ja bei uns das ding war credentials usernamen ja usernamen
ist das gleiche wie unser unser api key was da zwar nirgendswo steht aber ok api key data
passwort der da gehts jetzt meine fresse so schwierig kann es doch nicht sein ok da machen
wir das so das heißt wir müssen den ganzen krempel von selbst anhängen selbst anhängen
das ist nicht schön sondern müssen wir das den krams noch irgendwie adden kann ich einfach
basic auf oder so reinschreiben ok ich mach das jetzt einfach mal wieder typ das angeblich
dass es funktioniert ok gehts jetzt es geht krass wo stellt man die taskleiste so ein
was welche die wir noch sassleiste oder oder meinst du hier meine meine linux vm
wie sieht denn so der richtige header aus einfach so moin cheesy pro 36 ja so funktioniert
ok und das byte array müsste jetzt unser waff sein oder ich vermute mal schon also
sagen wir files save save save wie ging das falls du im save konnte gab es gab es gab
doch irgendwie dort net neues dings für feilspeichern dass man kein extra feil streamer brauche
braucht ja oder nie der stream hat der stream hatte nun das safe s irgendwie so war das
aber ich bin mir ein ich hab letztens gelesen dass es irgendwie eine neue funktion gab für
byte to feil ja genau so war das ja so dann ist halt so und das sollte eigentlich jetzt
unsere monka s waff datei sein ich hoffe mal das kommt da jetzt irgendwie hin gucken
wir mal ich hab ja meine zweifel ob das funktioniert funktioniert funktioniert krass das hätte
ich nicht gedacht dass es einfach so geht ein sehr sehr nicer download ok nachdem wir
jetzt prinzipiell wissen wie das funktioniert kann man das das nächste mal in das meme tool
einbauen ja und jetzt wie gesagt für alle jetzt neu dabei sind zu erklären was ich
eigentlich vor hab wir haben wir hier meinen ja das ist die neue version hier dieses tool
mit für overlays und so was also das ist eigentlich dafür gedacht dass man das auf
dem zweiten rechner verwendet also gleichen rechner ist bescheuert man kann diesen bildchen
kann man shortcuts zuweisen hier wie zum beispiel steuerung f10 ist hier poggers so und dann
macht man sich auf dem zweiten rechner macht man sich das auf und da kann man dann halt
sachen öffnen die momentan die shortcuts nicht merken kann hier zum beispiel eats oder
sowas was halt für leute die stream oder youtube videos machen oder so halt mit mit wenn halt
irgendwas aufzeichnen ist echt praktisch ist wenn du irgendwas anzeigen willst dass du
eben selber siehst im obs kannst du nur einstellen dass es ist die leute sehen und hier siehst
es halt selbst wir haben noch ein obs overlay das ist das hier das ist quasi man sieht
es also im hintergrund das ist wenn man wenn man möchte dass es eben nicht hier angezeigt
wird selbst sondern nur im obs da kann man das ausschalten dass er das bild hier oben
anzeigt und man hat hier quasi ein extra browser fenster was man quasi im obs hinzufügen
kann also jeder wie er will so und jetzt wollen wir dem ding natürlich nicht nur bildchen
anzeigen lassen können sondern auch text to speech und dann natürlich mit schönen
vielen verschiedenen voice dingern dafür haben wir jetzt schön japanische voice api gefunden
mit der man das machen kann so und jetzt müssen wir diese komische world encode geschichte
noch mal verwenden world encode das jetzt zum ausprobieren es funktioniert speaker gleich
so mal gucken ob das jetzt so funktioniert encoded was da jetzt falsch
was war ich jetzt hier verkehrt ach quatsch ich will ja gar nicht alles world encode da
beknackt ich will nicht alles world encode ich will eigentlich nur das hier world encode
alles das ist was ich mit dem lehrzeichen drinne brauche also machen wir jetzt irgendwie
sowas hier so ich muss ja gleich pizza essen und danach
spielen wir noch eine runde plekops hast du noch vor eine twitch integration zu bauen
also dass der chat die memes triggern kann ja das habe ich mir alles schon aufgeschrieben
ich habe eine riesen liste mit was wir noch alles einbauen werden das 40 halt ein bisschen
hinziehen da wobei nie wir können es gibt jetzt irgendwas neues es gab irgendwie neue
string interpolation gab es doch jetzt habe ich gesehen irgendwie in c sharp 6 oder 7
es ist neu weiß ich bloß die sonntags nicht mehr ah ja so genau da braucht man nämlich
den ganzen miss nicht mehr und dann aber da kann man das einfach einsetzen ja das ist
schön sehr sehr nice alter wo ist das problem jetzt
ich bin irgendwie geradezu unfähig für ich muss das nicht ich muss den muss wahrscheinlich
nur monka es encode
kannst du mal die neue version von mir bohr zeigen ja war ich gleich
ok nice ok dann weiß ich jetzt wieder kam es funktioniert sehr schön und jetzt haben
wir hier wahrscheinlich unsere audio audio datei mit einem punkt dazwischen sollte jetzt
eigentlich länger brauchen beim aussprechen
wunderbar ja die neue version von mir bohr zeige ich klar
ja die neue version die ist deutlich ordentlicher als die alte besteht jetzt aus zwei projekten
nämlich dem web frontend und der wpf anwendung die halt die das overlay anzeigt und wie gesagt
es ist aber halt noch nicht alles drinne was in der alten version drinne ist auch das css
ist deutlich ordentlicher kann es ja mal zeigen gerade das css ist deutlich ordentlicher das
javascript ist deutlich ordentlicher und das html ist tatsächlich auch deutlich ordentlicher
da blick ich auch noch durch das heißt wir können es auch besser erweitern irgendwie
ich zeig mir die neue version 51001 müssen wir da ist jetzt nicht viel drinne außer
jetzt aber was man hier sieht zum beispiel also der große unterschied warum warum ich
überhaupt gesagt habe ich muss das noch mal grundlegend anders verändern ist die alte
version also sprich die ich hier gerade die ganze zeit noch offen hatte da hast du quasi
die ganzen bilder hier im filesystem liegen gehabt inklusive allen informationen für
die bilder also sprich du hattest im dateinamen irgendwie ganz kryptisch musstest du reinschreiben
auch für welchen shortcut du für das bild verwenden willst und sowas was natürlich
auch dazu geführt hat dass man manche sachen überhaupt nicht machen konnte also sprich
wenn ich jetzt irgendwie will dass ich noch eine beschreibung für so ein bild vergeben
kann ja eine beschreibung ich dann hier oben später auch durchsuchen kann geht das nicht
weil du hast halt nur den dateinamen letztendlich und den den shortcut in den dateinamen rein
zu entkonen ist natürlich auch nicht nicht sonderlich tolle deswegen habe ich gedacht
wir machen da einfach eine sqlite datenbank unten drunter wo die da sachen drin gespeichert
werden die bilder werden im separaten ordner gespeichert weil bilder in der datenbank
speichern ist meistens ich wein bei der anzahl von bildern es ist scheißegal aber eigentlich
muss es nicht unbedingt sein sowas ist auf dem filesystem besser aufgehoben und das heißt
wenn man dieses jetzt ein neues bild nimmt aber das hast du bewusst gemacht mit dem
dateinamen ja ja habe ich habe ich habe ich so gemacht ich wollte das damals möglichst
easy haben bis mir dann aufgefallen ist nachdem ich dann eine weile verwendet habe dass es
das eigentlich viel komplizierter macht du kannst nämlich ein manche sachen schlicht
ergreifend ich macht nichts nicht machen wie beispielsweise eine beschreibung hinterlegen
für für für dieses bildchen also ich könnte sagen ok ich tagge meine bilder quasi für
den jeweiligen anlass sowas was ich hab funny bilder ich hab bible thumb bilder ich hab
was auch immer ja und wenn ich danach suchen will geht das nicht weil das kann ich in
datainamen nicht nicht reinschreiben was auch überhaupt nicht funktionieren würde
ist wenn ich zum beispiel ein bild plus den text to speech haben möchte auf einer sache
geht nicht weil wie soll ich hier den text to speech hinterlegen weil ich ja schon nur
den datainamen also das funktioniert nicht richtig deswegen kann man in der neuen version
kann man jetzt sagen ok wir nehmen das bild track und drop das rein dann geht ein pop
up auf wo ich sagen kann ich will das ding namen haben ich will text haben sowas weiß
ich happy was weiß ich happy irgendwas lull robbe was immer irgendwas oder das ist toller
text irgendwas also was weiß ich nicht in datainamen das kann ich eine datenbank speichern
unter kann ich gleichermaßen noch sagen ok ich möchte dass dieser text vorgelesen wird
also könnte ich zum beispiel sagen dann sage ich jawoll ich will dass das nicht nur das
bild angezeigt wird sondern auch text vorgelesen wird dann mache ich den muteknopf aus suche
mir eine schöne stimme aus zum beispiel unsere japanische weep emotestimme und also das
geht natürlich über den webservice vorher weil ich weiß ja nicht was da für ein text
drinne steht ja und dann drücke ich upload und dann ist das ding da und das css ist komisch
formatiert dann ist es da und das ist deutlich sauberer und schöner als noch in der alten
version und noch mal eine sache was auch ganz cool ist man hat jetzt ein ordentliches dark
und light theme das hat man in der alten version zwar auch schon gehabt das ist die alte version
hier aber ich fand es ehrlich gesagt nicht nicht so schick und halt mit den ganzen beschränkungen
die man auch drinne hatte deswegen kann man jetzt jetzt sagen zum beispiel light theme
takt sieht immer noch sehr schick aus rot ist rot grün ist grün aber in jeweils einem
anderen ton und jetzt wieder dunkel wobei dark theme ist natürlich die fault weil es
besser aussieht wäre cool wenn man sich die stimme anhören kann bevor man das auf hochladen
drückt ja ja das machen wir auch noch ich habe wir machen hier noch so ein brief you
play button dann da kann man sich einmal anhören wie es ist wobei man es halt immer hochladen
kann und dann und dann quasi im nachhinein noch mal editieren also sprich man kann es
im nachhinein noch mal editieren das funktioniert zum beispiel noch nicht richtig wenn ich jetzt
hier mittlere mittlere maus lasse drück dass das dann hat er jetzt war da stehen edit aber
er ändert das noch nicht richtig und da kann ich am nachhinein immer noch umstellen das
ist ja deswegen habe ich ja auch gerade mit der sq light datenbank im hintergrund gemacht
wenn das der urheber rechtsverletzung simulator das hängt von demjenigen ab der es benutzt
was er reinzieht standardmäßig kommt das ohne bilder wie sollte es auch anders sein
ich werde mich hüten irgendwelche bilder standardmäßig mit zu liefern vielleicht
irgend so ein pepe ding könnte man standardmäßig mitliefern ich weiß nicht wie es da copyright
technisch aussieht jaja ice naps genau das soll dass das soll da auch noch rein ja also
wie gesagt das ist noch nicht auf dem stand von dem von der ersten version alles jaja
das soll da rein also das können wir gerade mal machen das soll auf jeden fall rein also
sprich an der stelle wo jetzt hier ist das upload pop-up da könnte man jetzt zum beispiel
rein machen also ihr sagt da bla bla text to speech so und da machen wir jetzt noch
einen da machen wir jetzt noch einen label hotkey hotkey ja model haben wir dafür noch
nicht das müssen wir hier eintragen hotkey ja ja so ist das gedacht so und wenn wir das
jetzt noch mal reloaden wenn ich mich jetzt nicht verschrieben habe dann sollte es da
eine feld für hotkey geben dass der label text stimmt noch nicht placeholder text hotkey
ja ja so ist das gedacht so und wenn man dann den den hotkey eingetragen hat und auf upload
drückt also zum beispiel wir müssen uns mal überlegen wie man die synthax machen ob wir
sowas hier sagen control plus plus g oder irgendwie sowas oder ob wir standardmäßig
control nehmen und hier nur g eintragen mal gucken da könnte man ja in den setting draus
machen was quasi der globale key modifier ist also sprich ob es control ist ob es alt
alt plus control oder alt shift oder so das kann sich dann derjenige aussuchen das verwendet
genau aber wie du es wie du es geschrieben hast eben snaps i snaps ich weiß jetzt gar
nicht was geschrieben hat i snaps so ist das gedacht ja ja oder genau wie das hier ist
machen top down für control alt das können wir alles so machen ja richtig ja man könnte
sogar capturen lassen man könnte sogar capturen lassen dass man sagen hier jetzt taste drücken
und dann haben wir das ja und weil grad jemand schreibt das ist das ist ein gutes beispiel
weil grad jemand schreibt alt plus f4 das ist ein typischer fall von shortcut ist schon
belegt und das ist auch was was wir noch hinkriegen müssen ich zeige euch ich zeige euch nämlich
mal wieder upload funktioniert an der stelle also sprich wenn man auf diesen upload button
drückt dann äh wo ist der upload button da upload button dann wird ach ne in der form
stehts wenn sie den view da form in der form genau dann wird die wird hier in meinem javascript
die funktion upload aufgerufen die upload funktion sieht man hier upload aber grad ist
das in visual studio kacke upload so upload und dann sieht man was er letztendlich macht
es hält sich sehr in grenzen was was hier passiert ich der sagt erstmal standard wir
führen keine standard aktion durch weil wir wollen selbst uploaden dann nimmt er sich
das form element was man in view nicht so macht ich weiß aber nicht wie man es in dem fall
anders machen soll nimmt alles was in der form drinne steht also sprich den text den
namen den hotkey plus das bild hängt das an und lädt das hoch auf meinen asp.net webservice
als post mit mit der mit dem datenaus aus dem aus dem formular lädt er das ganze hoch
so was man jetzt braucht ist eigentlich weil nach dem upload geht auch das popup nicht
zu und so was eigentlich müssen wir jetzt noch die rückmeldung einbauen was schief
gelaufen ist weil es hat ja gerade einer gesagt man kann alt plus f4 angeben könnte könnte
ich ja ohne probleme machen ich könnte sie sagen als hotkey möchte ich alt plus f4
könnte ich machen problem ist jetzt das ist ja schon belegt das ist ja ein globaler hotkey
von winnows und spätestens wenn ich hier set hotkey wenn ich hier den hotkey registrieren
will was aktuell immer nur hardcode und l macht aber da kommt dann auch der richtige
hotkey rein hier registrieren gibt das ein fehler da sagt er mir hallo achtung exception
alt plus f4 ist schon ja error handling ist komplett debated overrated dann wird er mir
hier sagen der hotkey ist schon belegt das heißt ich brauche jetzt noch einen weg zurück
also sprich ich müsste hier irgendwas antworten im falle der fälle wie gesagt error handling
ist komplett overrated brauchen wir nicht so gehen wir mal in den controller also an der
stelle wenn ich auf upload drücke wird auf serverseite das hier ausgeführt ein bisschen
weg daneben das ist alles mehr passiert nicht also nur diese partizellen werden auf serverseite
ausgeführt und unter anderem guck wie ihr die datei nennen muss und so was ist aber
eigentlich relativ egal hier sagt er dann zum beispiel mit hotkeys setzen sollen jetzt
müsste ich anstatt return ok machen hier irgendwie return error im falle von hotkeys
schon belegt so sieht es aus cool story max aber das müssen wir machen und dann würde
er beispielsweise hier im formular anzeigen wenn ich auf upload drücke dann fehler anzeigen
hotkeys schon belegt wie wäre es mit einer implementierung für android beziehungsweise
um die memes zu drücken zu triggern so könnten die streamer keinen zweiten pc haben ja auf
jeden fall auf jeden fall plus wir brauchen dafür gar keine app weil du kannst einfach
den browser des webinterface aufmachen das webinterface versuche ich so zu designen dass
das auch auf mobile funktioniert ein paar sachen brauchen wir dafür noch aktuell werden
zum beispiel das editieren passiert hier mit mittel mittlerer maustaste das ist absolut
nicht standard und checkt eh keiner wir werden das einfach so machen wir machen oben edit
knopf dann geht es in edit modus man kann die dinger löschen und wir machen es einfach
so ein langer touch weil das kennt man ja von von mobile sachen ein langer touch auf
dieses ding macht den macht das edit popup auf und da müssen wir eigentlich nur noch
für das hinzufügenden knopf machen dass man zeug hochladen kann aber auf der anderen
seite brauchen wir das initial erstmal gar nicht weil die bilder und so das kann man
ja alles vom pc hinzufügen und gut ist und das triggern vom smartphone ist super einfach
du machst die seite auf und tatsch mit dem knopf hier drauf oder tatsch mit dem knopf
hier drauf mit dem nicht mit dem top du tatsch mit dem finger da drauf oder da drauf und
dann geht das bild halt auf wenn es läuft weil im hintergrund habe ich es ja ausgemacht
gerade also ich meine dafür brauchen wir keinen dafür brauchen wir eigentlich keine
smartphone app in dem sinn ich meine
weil ich meine also ich fühle noch mal irgendwas
bringt was hinzu ein bisschen das ein bisschen mehr drinne ist
weil ich auch wie schön fluid das ganze ist ja fluid wie heißt responsive responsive
heißt ja steht an die web leute drauf responsive ist guckt hier guck mal wie krass responsive
das ist bän alter ist das responsive
so und das kann man sich einfach auf dem tablet aufmachen und dann nimmt man seinen finger
und sagt tatsch tatsch tatsch
tatsch tatsch tatsch tatsch ich habe ein bug er switcht keine bilder ich muss bilder
ausmachen ok
ja aber wie gesagt die neue version ist noch nicht fertig deswegen werde ich dir auch nicht
auf github hochladen das sollte zumindest erstmal die gleiche versinke das gleiche können
Wie die alte Version und dann lade ich es hoch
Brauche ich auch ein paar Tage für bis das dann ordentlich ist
Genau das macht man sich dann auf dem zweiten Monitor auf
Oder auf einem Tablet auf
Oder auf seinem Smartphone auf
Oder auf seiner Smartwatch
Kann das sowas?
Ian
Ian nicht oder?
Kann man, kann man auf eine Apple Watch touchen?
Geht das?
Hat eine, hat eine Apple Watch in einem Browser?
Jetzt ernst gemeinte Frage, ich hab keine Ahnung
Preme oder kostenlos mit Season Pass?
Na, Season Pass ist out
Season Pass macht man nicht mehr
Wir machen in-game Transactions
Äh, nicht in-game, wir machen in-App Käufe
Machen wir
Nein, nicht wirklich
Ja, also sprich
Ähm, wer das Bild länger als zwei Sekunden anzeigen will
Der muss das natürlich erstmal anloggen
Du kannst es anloggen entweder
50 Cent Paypal Überweisung oder in-game oder in-App Käufe
Oder in dem man irgendwelche komischen Challenges erfüllen will
Wie klicke das Bild 20.000 Mal an
Und nachdem das keiner machen will, kauft sich's jeder
So machen wir das
Nee, das wird natürlich weiter
Also Scherz beiseite
Lull
Ähm, das wird natürlich kostenlos auf GitHub für alle zur Verfügung stehen
Jeder kann das verwenden was er will
Erstellt noch ein Testing Branch
Ja, ich erstelle den Testing Branch und auf GitHub wenn es erstmal ansatzweise läuft
Ja, zum Beispiel wenn ich so einen tollen Bug drin hab
Wie das Bild nicht switchen kannst
Ist schon mal absolut hängen geblieben
Und außerdem hab ich noch ein paar Comments drin stehen
Sinnlos von mir zusammen gebastelt
Ja
Warum krieg ich eigentlich so viele Follows gerade?
Alter, was denn da los?
Danke für die ganzen Follows, ich guck grad mal rein
Aber ich mein gut
Heute sind wir auch nicht einfach einen Programming Stream
Oder einfach einen Creative Stream
Heute sind wir ein Science and Technology Stream
Und da kann dabei eigentlich schon mal gar nichts schiefgehen
Ja, ich seh leider nur die letzten paar Follows
Danke für die Follows
Schokoladen
Soße
Burns Gaming
Mirikari
Burner
Jb
Äh, yyb
Nicht jb
Sag mal, habt ihr manchmal auch das Problem?
Oder ist das einfach nur brain lag bei mir?
Dass ihr y und j
Y, y, y, y
Und dass ihr das teilweise im Kopf durcheinander bringt
Das ist, äh
Denk ich über mein Gehirn, zersetzt sich oder so
Aber manchmal krieg ichs nicht hin
Ja, ähm
Wer haben wir noch am Start?
Hallo Gretz
DesertGamer001
Der Boy Next Door ist auch da
H
K
T
W
Icore
CS
VideoShark
Und mehr seh ich leider nicht
Weil die History nicht reicht
Warum kann man sich
Warum kann man sich nicht
Die History einfach länger anzeigen lassen?
Das ist ganz schön blöd
Ja, sorry
Für alle die jetzt
Ah, ich find schön, dass ihr da seid
Wie kann man donaten?
Wenn du donaten möchtest, kannst du einfach auf die
Channel
Info-Page, also da auf die Kanalseite gehen
Da ist ein Paypal-Link
Aber, wie gesagt
Muss keiner donaten
Sollte eigentlich auch
Im Endeffekt keiner
Wozu?
Ja
Mir reicht schon, wenn euch das
Wenn euch das
Äh
Geschwätze von mir soweit
Gefällt, dass ihr nicht abhaut
Dann ist alles gut
Ich brauch da keine Kohle für
Ich mach den ganzen Kram ja eh nicht
Für die Kohle
Geld verdien ich mit der Arbeit genug
Und dann brauch ich das nicht
Mir ist natürlich immer gut
Da sagt natürlich keiner was zu
Wenn ich wirklich Kohle verdienen möchte
Mit Twitch
Dann werd ich irgendwann mal tatsächlich
Twitch-Partner oder sowas
Oder Affiliate oder so in der Richtung
Aktuell mach ich das einfach nur aus Spaß und Freude
Was auch den großen Vorteil hat
Ich mein, ich kann machen was ich will
Wenn ich jetzt quasi
Wenn ich jetzt Sellout machen müsste
Nachdem ich gestern im Video gesagt hab
Ihr könnt ja mal beim Stream vorbeigucken
Und ich
Mach ein bisschen Black Ops
Und ich geh jetzt online
Und mach kein Black Ops
Ist das natürlich aus Sellout-Sicht ganz schlecht
Aus Sellout-Sicht müsste ich jetzt Black Ops machen
Und nicht irgendwelche komischen
Meme-Overlay-Dinger programmieren
Das ist ja, ne
Fail
Ist euch mal aufgefallen
Wie schnell das Ganze ist
Trotz Datenbank-Axis im Hintergrund
Aber ich mein der Datenbank ist auch nix drin
Warum sollte das langsam sein
Ja
So siehts aus
Und
Wir haben jetzt sogar unseren schönen
Japanischen
Was ist denn das da unten
Auch unsere schöne japanische Text-to-Speak
Text-to-Speech
Wie wärs mit einer neuen Gartentour
Hab ich doch erst letztens
Oder
Hab ich das nicht erst letztens
Was ist das
Ergebnis für MaxFPS
Geboren, Eintracht, Dezember 1984
Moment
Warum
steht öffentlich
auf Google
den Geburtstag
den ich in meinem Profil drin
aufstehen hab
Das ist richtig Illuminati
Weil ich bin nicht eingeloggt
Wenn ich eingeloggt wäre
würde ich sagen ok versteh ich
Tja
Hast du mal erwähnt in nem Video
Nee hab ich nicht
Weil Eintracht, Dezember ist nehm ich sogar falsch
Ähm
Das ist irgendwas was Google selbst
anbietet
Das heißt in dem Fall
scheißt Google auf meine Privacy-Settings
Weil ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
Ich hab nirgendswo in meinem Profil eingestellt
dass man davon was
sehen darf
Oh guck mal ich hab ne eigene
YouTube Wikia-Seite
Was steht denn da
Mal gucken
Was steht denn da so drauf
Reject
Ich will keine Cookies
Das ist outdated
Ich hab mittlerweile weniger
Weil ich nix hochgeladen hab
So
Sein ältestes noch verfügbares Video
hat er am 25.10.2010 hochgeladen
Das kann sogar sein
Was ist
Was ist mein ältestes Video
Mein ältestes Video ist
Das erste Video ist es nicht
Da hatte ich Musik drin
Das hab ich gelöscht
Das zweite Video war irgendwas
über Headsets
Das könnte ein Video über Headsets sein
Es ist entweder ein Video über Headsets
Oder
Backyard Court 4 mit Hacker
Eins von beiden
Das ist
Das ist Greek
Greek Court 4 auf
Ähm
Wo ich was über Headsets erzähle
Oder es ist Backyard mit
Hacker
Bäm
Alter
Ok
Es ist District mit Hacker
Aber
Ne
Ich weiß es noch
Hehehe
Ja
Das ist schon ein bisschen her
Warum
Kotz sacken muss
Tja Max
Warum ist das so
Erzähl's mir
Was steht denn hier noch so
So was steht denn hier noch so
Dieses wurde leider gelöscht
In seinem
Erzähl der verschiedenstenes
Wer
Wer erstellt solche Seiten
Eigentlich
Pausenlos
Pausenlos ist gut
Ja
Pausenlos
Werden mir alle zustimmen können
Dass ich
Pausenlos Videos mache
Pausenlos
Ich mein ich find das cool
Dass ich da auf irgendeiner
YouTube Wiki Seite
Einen Eintrag hab
Warum nicht
Das ist doch nice
News über Terroristen
Auf der Playstation
Toilettenland Bahnhof
Ok die Videos haben
Anscheinend Eindruck gemacht
Ok
Tja
Seine Videos sind immer lustig
Und informativ
Meistens sind sie jedoch
Beides gleichzeitig
Das ist ja
Wahnsinn
Was es nicht alles gibt
Ich hoffe dass die Videos
Lustig und informativ
Gleichzeitig sind
So ist das gedacht
Ich will Scheißbilder
Ich kenn das eigene
Oh
Leaked
Face leaked
Hier mein patentiertes
Gaming Video
Ja
Was ich manchmal
Siehste
Ich merke mir das
Überhaupt nicht
Wenn ich so einen Mist
Poste
Ich wusste überhaupt nicht
Mehr bis eben
Dass ich das überhaupt
Gepostet hab
Ja das bin ich mit dem
Kaboom zusammen
Fällt mir da gerade so auf
Nachdem es schon so
Lang her ist
Kann ich euch fragen
Was meint ihr wer ich bin
Von beiden
Das hat voll
Eingeschrieben
Ja wahrscheinlich
Debated
Ich bin links
Nicht rechts
Der da
Das ist der Kaboom
Das bin ich
Aber man muss schon
Ehrlich sagen
Wir sehen uns da
Sehr ähnlich
Sowohl vom
Vom Haar
Mittlerweile habe ich
Hier noch
Eine ganze Ecke
Weniger Haare oben drauf
Wir sehen uns
Von hinten
Irgendwie
Ich bin nicht im Kindergarten
Dabei
Ja so ist es
Gut
Oh Mann
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Wie ich darauf gekommen bin
Ich wollte
Irgendwas gucken
Auf YouTube
Ich habe vergessen
Was wollte ich
Auf YouTube gucken
Ach so wie viele
Abos ich jetzt habe
Ja es ist
Natürlich ein bisschen weniger
Mittlerweile
Gibt ja
Wenn man keine
Videos hochlädt
Gibt es auch keine Abos
Suche am besten auch mal
Open Source Lizenz raus
Damit Pork nicht
Problematisch
Ich werde schon keinen
Verklagen
Ja
Ich wein
Kann ich machen
Letztendlich
Ist immer gut
Wenn man eine gewisse
Sicherheit hat
Aber
Ich meine
Wenn ich im Stream sage
Quasi
Kann man das im Zweifelsfall
Ja auch
Quoten
Falls ich doch mal
Irgend einen
Verklagen sollte
Aber warum sollte ich das machen
Neuestes Video mit
Sellout
Irgendwas
Ja genau
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt
Black Ops 4 machen
Irgendwie
Weil ich
Gucke hier Video von
Gestern
Ich habe seit einem halben
Jahr oder so
Ja das das das zähl ich
So diese zwei
Dinge zwischendurch
Also im Prinzip
Ich habe dieses Jahr
Doch ich habe am Anfang des
Jahres habe ich viel
Hochgeladen
Aber ich habe ein halbes Jahr
Mehr oder weniger nichts
Hochgeladen
Fast nichts
Und trotzdem
Und das ist halt das was ich immer
Irgendwie krass finde
Und trotzdem
Hat das Ding jetzt mittlerweile
Schon an die 2000
Likes
Und wahrscheinlich
Irgendwann
Bis es aktualisiert ist
Nächstes Mal
Irgendwie
Keine Ahnung
20.000 Views
Oder so
Comments
Vor allem Leute die sich
Freuen
Dass ich wieder
Am Start bin
Das finde ich halt
Echt nice
Letztendlich
Ja
Ich finde
Das ist
Dass der Channel
War halt einfach
Komplett
Tod in
Ein halbes Jahr
Und trotzdem
Sind die Leute
Noch am Start
Das ist halt echt geil
So Leute müssen natürlich
Immer noch
An den Start kommen
Diese FPS Drops
Ja das hat
Shadowplay versaut
Also wer sich gewundert hat
Warum manche Sachen
In dem Video so rumruckeln
Hier
So wie zum Beispiel
Jetzt ruckelt es nicht
Aber manche Sachen ruckeln
Ja das zum Beispiel
Das war Shadowplay
Ich weiß nicht was Shadowplay
Für Schmerzen hatte
Weil ich die Pizza
Fertig
Die ist schon längst
Die steht schon hier
Diese FPS Drops
Ja
Wie lang bin ich denn eigentlich
Schon on
Uptime
Zwei Stunden
Ne
Leute
Und außer
Ein bisschen
Japanische Text
To Speech
Geschichte
Haben wir nichts
Gemacht
Nichts
Die Memetool Version
Gezeigt
Aber sonst nichts
Da hat er recht
Free for all
Ist quasi unspielbar
Da hat er recht
Ich war ja immer
Ein großer
Free for all Fan
Und ich würde fast schon sagen
So in
Den Zeiten
Wo ich quasi
Die Call of Duty
Teile
Die damals aktuell waren
Also quasi
Code 4, 5
Black Ops 1
MB2
Und sowas in der Richtung
Da würde ich schon fast sagen
War ich eigentlich fast schon
Free for all Spezialist
Das war der Modus
Der mir am besten gefallen hat
Weil es dort gefühlt
Am wenigsten Bullshit gab
Und es
Eigentlich nur auf dich ankam
Das heißt wenn
Du schlecht gespielt hast
Hast du meistens
Das selbst verkackt
Deswegen habe ich
Free for all gerne gespielt
Auch in den alten
Call of Duty
Allerdings muss ich echt
Muss ich sagen
In Black Ops 4
Ist
Free for all finde ich wirklich
Da muss ich ihm recht geben hier
Den Namen auszusprechen
Ist nicht politisch korrekt
Heutzutage werde ich bestimmt gebannt
Tryhard 7
Ja und das
Ist wirklich fast unspielbar
Das ist so schlimm
Weil
Black Ops 4 hat in Free for all
Schon noch so die typischen
Call of Duty Revenge Spawns
Also ihr kennt das ja
Wahrscheinlich noch
So nach dem Motto
Du killst einen
Und du kannst dir zu 99%
Sicher sein
Der Typ spawns jetzt hinter der
Nächsten Ecke hinter dir
Das heißt du kannst
Einen Schott fast umdrehen
Und das heißt du hast öfters
Dann auch mal durch diese
150 HP
Dass du quasi
Dass es übeles Chaos ist
Dass du einen killst
Und schon der nächste
Der nächste respawn
Schon wieder der andere
Sind richtig tot
Es ist
Scheiße zu spielen
Muss man ehrlich sagen
Also Free for all gefällt mir
Überhaupt gar nicht
So viel dazu
Muss ich jetzt einfach mal
Loswerden
Ist dein Deutsch schlechter geworden
Weiß ich nicht
Es gibt Jugendsprache
Es gibt Umgangssprache
Es gibt die Asi-Sprache
Es gibt die Magssprache
Ja es haben sich ja schon
So manche Sachen etabliert
Ich muss mal kurz gucken
Ob da Friseur am Start ist
Weil
Eigentlich wollten wir nachher
Noch eine Runde
Discord
Was besprechen
Nicht dass ich das jetzt
Verpasse oder so
Ist es nicht unmöglich
Drei Leute auf einmal zu killen
Also wenn man sich das Video anguckt
Ist es nicht unmöglich
Da kill ich manchmal drei Leute
Auf einmal oder mehr oder weniger
Auf einmal
Allerdings
Es ist fast unmöglich
Also es ist frontal unmöglich
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher
Wie gut die
Diese Bullet Penetration noch ist
Ich hab das Gefühl
Die Schüsse gehen
Nur noch ziemlich schlecht
Durch Gegner durch
Oder durch Teammates durch
Weiß nicht ob das Unterschied
Ist zu den alten Cots
Also zu den älteren
Weil die letzten paar
Hab ich ja nicht gespielt
Wirklich
Gefühlt schon
Das Problem ist
Drei Gegner kriegst du
Kaumdown
Frontal auf gar keinen Fall
Und
Also selbst wenn sie
Perfekt laufen
Also auch irgendwie so diese
Diese Sniper
Zwiegst du die
Collateral Geschichten
Naja
Und du kriegst die Gegner
Du kriegst drei Gegner
Auch von hinten nicht richtig
Down
Weil
So einen Turn
Mit der Maus zu machen
Kriegt jeder halbwegs
Schnell hin
Und
Wenn im Controller
Ist es vielleicht
Noch ein bisschen schwieriger
Aber
Gut gepflankt
War in älteren Call of Duty
Vor allem in Team Deathmatch
Wenn man jetzt halt nicht
Diese Streak
Geschichte machen wollte
Oder Teammates sie
Supportet haben
Und quasi Solo Team
Deathmatch gespielt
Wollte ordentlich was reißen
Da hast du es ja oftmals
Für die
Für einen guten Start
Und für die
Quasi dass man
Kills kriegst vor den anderen
Kriegt
Muss man eine gute
Flank Aktion machen
Und das kannst du im
Black Ops 4 komplett vergessen
Kannste knicken
Du flankst
Kills eins
Zwei
Und der dritte
Dreht sich halt in der
Zwischenzeit um
Und killst dich
Kannste
Kannste knicken
Und ja das ist auch noch
So eine Sache
Das finde ich
Schwierig
Weil sobald man sich
Aus den Augen verliert
Kann man sich eigentlich
Sicher sein
Ich drück mir jetzt
Eine Spritze rein
Und der Gegner
Drückt sich jetzt auch
Einen Stimpack rein
Und ist wieder
Auf 100%
Dafür kann man
Und das finde ich
Eigentlich in Black Ops 4
Ganz schön
Dafür kann man
Einen halbwegs
Gutes
Anti Bullshit
Perk Setup machen
Man kann sich nämlich
Als
Als ins erste
Perk Slot
Kann man sich reinpacken
Tactical Mask
Und Flak Jacket
Wenn man
Die Perk hat
Dass man
Zwei Stück verwenden kann
Da nimmt man noch
Irgendwie sowas wie
Light White
Und Ghost
Oder sowas
Und dann ist man
Vor relativ viel Bullshit
Eigentlich sicher
Eigentlich ja
Es gibt genug
Anderen Bullshit
Aber man kann sich
Find ich ein ganz gutes
Anti Bullshit Perk Setup
Zusammen basteln
Plus dann kann man
Noch den Operator nehmen
Den man auch
Einfach
Am liebsten hat
Indem man ihm
Quasi dann noch
Ein zusätzliches
Gadget in die Hand
Drückt
Also ich kann zum
Beispiel sagen
Wenn ich den Operator
Mit dem Hund am liebsten
Spiele
Oder den Operator
Mit dem One Shot
Revolver
Ach Ghost
Funktioniert nicht
Tja
Es ist eh
Ziemlich viel kaputt
In dem Game
Und dann kann ich dann
Quasi sagen
Okay wenn ich jetzt
Irgendwie wie heißt
Die Seraph oder so
Spiele
Finde ich zum
Beispiel
Das Spawnpeaken doof
Weil das
Naja
Team Deathmatch heißt
Zwar Team
Aber in Call of Duty
Spielt keiner
Team Deathmatch als Team
Das heißt
Da kann ich
Das Spawnpeaken für den Punkt
Auswechseln
Zu einer
Zu einer Frac oder so was
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool
Ich finde das Perk System
Gar nicht schlecht diesmal
Das Game hat
Sau viele Bugs
Wenn man mal auf
Reddit guckt
Da hast du hier
Einen der sich
Aufregt
Dass man permanent
200 HP hat
Beim Spawn
Das
Emote
Clitch
Kennt ihr den
Emote
Clitch
Den Blackout
Emote
Clitch
Auch
Auch sehr beliebt
Das
Irgendwie
Was habe ich
Genau das 200 HP
Spawn
Das
Nein
Übelst
Audience
Der
Ist
PLESS
also sprich du hast du sagst dann ich will jetzt irgendwie keine ahnung
hinsatz emote machen und dann geht die kamera von egoperspektive auf
third party
third-person view und du siehst mehr
also sprich du kannst dich zum beispiel du machst einen sitz emote auf einem dach
und dich sieht keiner mehr weil du auf dem dach sitzt du selbst kannst aber rumgucken
third-person alles was um das haus drumherum ist das ist übelst unfair in blackout und
warum da keiner beim testen drauf gekommen ist mir vollkommen
schleierhaft ja vollkommen also da hast du fast das gefühl das game hat man wieder keiner getestet
schreck spawn in black ops 4
das finde ich sogar ganz cool irgendwie
ja die rüstung in blackout sind auch extrem gut
footstep sounds sind mega broken da hat er recht
footstabs hörst du manchmal drei kilometer weit manchmal gar nicht manchmal kannst du nicht zuordnen wo sie herkommen
wenn man duo spielt ich habe ja vorhin paar runden mit dem eax duo gespielt blackout
footstabs kommen aus zwei verschiedenen richtungen teilweise also sprich
wir sind gelandet auf array der eax auf dem dach ich bin unten in das haus rein
und der ist über mir auf dem dach gelaufen und dadurch hat sich so angehört als kommen quasi gegner von der anderen seite das war ganz ganz
wir also fuß also
fußschritte sind komplett kaputt in den game
was auch komisch ist dass man diese effekt sounds nicht ausschalten kann also diese diese
metals die man kriegt in game kann man den sound nicht ausschalten
genau spawning in in s crash mit 200 hells das ist auch ein schöner wacke
smg sollten tatsächlich gebufft werden sich auch bis auf eine ist die sind die eigentlich ziemlich kacke
ja ddm endet tatsächlich ein bisschen bisschen früh finde ich auch
aber da zeigt ihr seine kurz sammlung da kann ich nicht beteiligen ich habe kurz
2 1 habe ich gar nicht mehr 2 habe ich auf dem pc 3 hatte ich nie 4 habe ich auf dem pc auf der ps 3
und auf der 360 vor habe ich auf der 360 2 habe ich auf der 360 360 3 3 habe ich auf der 360
black ops 2 und ghost auch wobei nie richtig gespielt advanced warfare habe ich auf dem pc
und auf der kam das schon auf der xbox 1 war das xbox 1 schon mit waffel oder war das noch 360
habe ich nämlich auf der xbox 1 das war das spiel wo ich festgestellt habe dass mir die xbox
1 controller schlechter gefällt als der 360 controller und pc black ops 3 habe ich nicht
infinite warfare habe ich auch nicht doch habe ich habe ich nicht infinite warfare habe ich nicht
advanced warfare war das mit kevin spacey oder infinite warfare weiß ich gar nicht was es da
ging ja world war 2 habe ich auf dem pc wobei nicht moment die beta habe ich gespielt doch
habe ich auch auf dem pc und das ja ich habe tatsächlich mehr kotz als ich es haben will
tja gut leute ich mache jetzt mal kurz aus und ist jetzt ein bisschen pizza wie heißt die musik
die gerade im hintergrund läuft chill step 24 sieben live stream chill ambient study musik hier
es sind ja something übrigens habe ich schon das beste das kann ich euch mal kurz zeigen
habe ich euch schon das beste gezeigt ich kann das nicht spielen mit dem account ich
habe das auf dem anderen account was passiert dann jetzt wenn ich das mit dem falschen account
starte ich habe das game mit dem account nicht ich bin mal gespannt was jetzt passiert
wahrscheinlich kackts ab oder so achso aber aber es kann sich nicht direkt na gut dann kann ich
das nachzudenken der theater modus ist richtig cool diesmal ist das etwa wie game sharing
das wäre geil wenn das funktioniert übrigens wisst ihr was auch komplett kaputt ist ich ich
wollte im ex das game giften über bettel net und das hat glaube ich drei stunden oder so gedauert
wenn es ist ein online shop das ist warum dauert das drei stunden im game zu giften das klickste
an der setzten fleck bei denen irgendwie in der datenbank für den user beim ex das auf
tru auf uns pleck auf vier oder so dann ist es da warum dauert es drei stunden wat ich
wein sogar mein komisches webinterface was gerade kaputt ist geht schneller 50 euro
court bis heute nicht bekommen ja ich weiß auch nicht was sie da machen man auf steam geht
es doch auch und ich meine auf steam ist mehr los deutlich mehr los als bettel net also shop mäßig
wahrscheinlich sitzt da der inne irgendwie mal blitz hat und muss je muss jedes gift
einzeln noch irgendwie bestätigen und eintippen oder so ich muss was essen
mein name ist peter
ich habe jetzt in so ein scam video geguckt wo wieder irgend so ein indischer microsoft support
angerufen hat ja also den zahl verarscht haben die haben halt dort angerufen haben gesagt ja hier
mein windows hat fehler und guckt euch das mal an ihr kennt ja weiß ich aber das kennt
diese diese indischen support in indischen microsoft fake support verarschungs videos
und da ging dann halt ein inne dran und hat sich nicht etwa gemeldet halt mit einem indischen
namen sondern meinte dann so irgendwie weil weil er hat halt gesagt der typ ich rufe auf
deutschland an oder geht an der inne dran von microsoft support mein so bei nah mein name ist
peter klingt sehr glaubwürdig ruft eine indische nummer an der typ hat sich so was von indisch an
ja spricht das schlechteste deutsch aller zeiten und will die erzählen heißt peter ist ist klar
ja ganz bestimmt bitte anlassen was man pizzer essen wollen wir eating sounds pizzer stream machen
oder aber diese die videos gucke ich mir gerne an diese microsoft scam videos also nicht
microsoft scam sondern fake microsoft support leute die gescampt werden was passiert wenn
man auf spam antwortet den vortrag kenne ich wobei ich will da nicht sicher bin wie gefaked da
manche sachen sind das ist das worauf irgendwie so eine nigeria spam email sie haben was geerbt
antwortet richtiger deutscher support meldet sich nicht mit vornamen das stimmt die legen
gleich wieder auf wenn du irgendwie bei juni die media oder so anruf ich habe schon kein
bock mehr dann solltest du die kita bock bock bock ja ich habe ein paar so channels kann
durchaus sein dass von ihnen sogar schon was geguckt haben ja so viele follows heute was
da los danke für die ganzen follows ich gucke noch mal rein wer ist jetzt hier neu
dabei gekommen der mosel 1337 gut guy michi ist am start the cry net little d 2608 schnitz
schnitzelwutz also manche namens sind tatsächlich kreativ irgendwie elwell 0711 de fabulous muffin
last defender xy na mehr sehe ich nicht kommen alle vom youtube video wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
denke ich auch so also ich werde jetzt meine pizza futtern und danach spielen wir ich sag
jetzt nicht hundertprozentig weil ihr wisst was passiert wenn ich sag ich mache das dann mache
ich es nicht also so wie video so nach dem auto bis zum nächsten mal und dann gibt es
demnächst noch oder dann mache ich das nicht deswegen sage ich jetzt nicht dass es danach
hundertprozentig noch ein bleck aus vier streben gibt aber ich sag mal ich habe noch nichts
anderes vor als den bleck auf vier streben zu machen nachdem ich meine pizza gefordert
haben und ich lasse den stream nicht an beim pizza futtern weil da muss ich mich so zurück
halten bei pizza essen da muss man da immer so gesitzt sein das geht nicht weil sonst hört sich
zu eklig an für die leute dass ich muss die pizza muss reingestopft werden heets heute mittag gab
sushi abend gibt es pizza also sprich heute mittags gab was gesundes heute abend gibt es
dann halt was auch sehr gesundes
immer so immer so pizza ja immer so audio 3d audio immer so pizza eating okay leute
war schön dass ihr dabei war wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich nachher noch mal mit bleck auf vier
bis gleich ich gehe jetzt mal in der pizza futtern bis dann see you